this podcast is brought to you by better
help my friends and genius brain
listeners do I have a treat for you
because better help is something that
I've been using for a very long time and
if you've listened to this podcast
you've heard me talk about mental health
I've even bought a therapist along
um on one episode to talk about mental
health so you know I really am about
that life if you're thinking of starting
therapy give better help a try it's
entirely online designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched up with the
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge
discover your potential with
betterhealth visit betterhelp.com genius
today to get 10 off your first month
that's betterhealth help help.com genius
but it's so crazy right like we're like
the biggest population in the world
right um
and like obviously you know not in the
United States but like it's just
interesting like we have our own unique
story too you know like we understand
obviously the the hardships of being
like a minority in the sense of like you
know five four three two one what's up
everybody welcome to another episode of
The Genius brain podcast if you guys are
a first time listener well you're in for
a [__] doozy because this episode
doesn't make any [__] sense at all
hey we have my buddy Robin here today
now on this podcast uh usually you guys
see a lot of people that you know you
might have seen on on the on online and
space and whatever but the other 30 of
the time I bring on people you don't
[__] know these are people that just
happen to be in my life you guys never
knew who Ed was do you know who the
other Ed was you didn't know who Nick or
Pat were but that's how my podcast rolls
if I don't like you you're not on this
[__] podcast period end of [__]
story and now we have Robin man and
there is so much to unpack because uh I
met Robin
it was at Dan's wedding actually we we I
was drunk as [__] though okay because I
the only thing I remember from the
wedding was the venue
and then it was also because that's
where I was like that's where I'm gonna
live next oh so you weren't living at
Lacey at the time no so that was I was
like
I like this oh I want this so yeah if
you guys want to know what wedding I'm
talking about if you listen to this
podcast Ed talked about this time that
he had to give a best man speech to his
best friend Dan and this is where Ed was
just rambling on
at the same wedding the the DJ slash MC
was [__] coming down from a coke high
so he was sweating through his [__]
tuxedo do you remember that well so
that's the thing right I didn't get the
behind the scenes
I was just there and most the time I was
just looking at the place saying this is
where I want to do my supper clubs so
check this [__] out so at the wedding
they hired this [__] like Armenian DJ
from Facebook and this guy comes
sweating through his whole tuxedo I'm
talking about the [__] 80s ruffle
tuxedo right and you look at him his
pupils are dilated I was like you are
doing coke and you're coming off a high
right now yeah so he was crashing hard
yeah and so the dude was grabbing the
mic just mumbling and so yeah yeah you
know our our major friend Clara she was
like crying or like tearing up I was
like all right because I've done
weddings right and I just I didn't want
to do it at this [__] wedding but I
was like okay let me just pull this out
of my ass grab the mic and I just emceed
the rest of the wedding
and so so he was high as [__] and that's
when Ed came up and he started giving
his speech which went on too long so I
grabbed the mic away from him and then I
kind of roast him a little bit he was a
little upset but this is a different end
than the one now back in the day Ed
couldn't take a joke very well but I had
no other choice I had to roast the guy
because it was so awkward you know what
I mean yeah I do I do remember wait was
that when Ed was doing the best man
speech
that was when Ed was doing the best man
speech okay because I remember a part of
that was there was a point where and I
think I've done this before or somebody
did it to me at some point in my life
but I will uh when Ed was talking you
know he was a bit nervous and then I
think I started uh holding up or oh
I think I said cheers yeah I don't know
whatever the case was I feel bad to that
day I always apologize to Ed whenever I
think about it oh no no that was a very
good move you made because if not it
would have gone a really dark rabbit
hole but it was like so he got he was it
was so [__] nervous yeah he drank a
[__] ton of like whiskey yeah yeah yeah
he got drunk as [__] but that backfired
because he was too drunk up there and
then after the the speech got cut in
half yeah he took Dan to a corner and
finished the rest of his speech to him
and the cool part about that is you guys
had your own crew and you know I I was
more on the bright side right so I had
met Dan that night
and then also after I think Dan had come
come up to me and then that's how he
kind of introduced himself about the
speech and then when I uh when I did the
Clapping or whatever but yeah
you know it was earlier when you were
talking
so I'm on THC right now so I'm
definitely High
there was a moment in time like leading
up to this right this is my first time
ever being on a podcast
so like
you know I'm not a nervous guy but then
also like you know like I'm also not
like a camera guy like you know in the
sense of like you know I've been in
front of the camera and stuff but like
actually talking it's uh
it's a scary thought to just never be on
something and then be on something oh
yeah 100 like even Ed before he came on
here like if you look at Ed's first
podcast and now he's completely
different right usually what happens on
this podcast from anybody who's been on
this podcast everybody usually has an
agenda like on a podcast oh this is the
subject matter this is what we're going
to talk about we need to get clicks I
don't give a [__] right yeah yeah and I
think like for me I don't know how I'm
still surviving in the podcast space
yeah yeah because usually people think
about clickbait [__] they think about
stuff that's really hot I only bring up
stuff that people ask me to talk about
and if it's hot it's hot if it's not
it's not I really don't care about it
because you know being on the space for
so long like you can't keep chasing this
[__] carrot dangling in front of your
face forever it's exhausting sometimes
you just want to drink wine and talk to
a [__] high Robin yeah yeah
sure for sure for sure so it's just like
it's super casual and I think like
that's what people get shocked about the
most like even people who are you know
veterans in this space they go oh like
this is a very casual podcast like yeah
I don't I don't really care to you know
exploit you for views or whatever
whatever I mean we're obviously friends
outside of uh 100 public profile person
yeah I'm talking about like like
celebrity friends it's like you know
we're we don't have to talk about
anything you don't want to talk about
there's plenty of other [__] we could
talk about you know
um
but like um this this this podcast
actually happened well let's just go
let's so
Robin and I only got to really know each
other probably in the last like couple
of years right and it obviously happened
because of our love for the UFC right
yeah that's definitely one of the
reasons that's one of them and the other
thing is because there's like Robin
likes to categorize two things there's
Foodies and then there's fat asses
guess what category we were in yeah
[__] fat asses yeah
fat ass
also includes
foodie as part of it
but I guess a foodie can't be a fat ass
in a way because
it's like a you know like when you're
like a desperate dude and you're just
gonna
any uh it's not it's just you don't have
clothes since you don't have since you
don't have like options you're gonna
take whatever you want you know or
whatever you can get right
like if you're a fatty if you have
something amazing you're gonna know it's
amazing too
but because you're gonna not like have
any like frame of like
standard you just got I'm gonna put that
[__] in my mouth yeah yeah there's still
some roots of how you grow at least for
me I grew up where
I grew up like you know it's like I've
eaten a lot of sushi in my life and I
can't keep up with the current as well
as my wallet can't keep up with like you
know where Sushi has gone but I grew up
on that Todai life oh yeah yeah yeah my
first time I ever had uh uh niggity was
like you know like the fish on over the
rice and stuff was at Todai and I was so
scared to eat that [__] like
I used bulgogi as uh you know like the
um you know the Korean uh marinated rib
eye I guess do I ever have to do
translations or should I just say it
just do the trans it helps with people
all right we're a word why people you
guys love it yeah
yeah yeah so I took [__] and I used
the pru Gogi as a chaser so like it was
like popping kogi but there just
happened to be some fish this is how I
was mentally preparing myself for this
you know you're a kid dude you get to a
certain point where like you think you
have it all all like figured out with
food and you're like this is what I like
this is what I don't like and if I
haven't tried it I don't want to do it
right yeah
but this is where the fatties get
separated from the booties no I guess
Foodies will try something adventurous
too but I was like legitimately scared
so I started eating it and then I was
like oh shoot this rice is so sticky and
like you know like you know whatever
what's whatever the stuff that goes in
uh you know rice wine vinegar whatever
you go whatever you do to make sushi
rice right it's not just steamed rice
right and that texture again it was
obviously not perfect but still like any
Asian owned place is still going to make
better rice than like a non-asian place
that's going to try to make Asian Rice
do you know what I mean yeah yeah yeah
so I used it as a chaser I ate it and it
was like
okay I could do this so the doubt was
like me normalizing eating raw fish over
a piece of rice you know what's so weird
like as a kid we you know so Korean
people had this dish it's called a head
up right yeah yeah so that's like raw
fish with uh gochujang like tangita
vegetables and rice hot rice cold fish
raw I used to hate that [__] when I was
a kid I [__] hated that was it
because it was cold or was it like a
bunch of other reasons it's just the raw
fish idea just I it turned me off I
didn't [__] like it and then I don't
know what it is but one day I'm like
this is pretty [__] good yeah yeah it
just happened overnight yeah yeah and my
mom used to know she was like you you
should never eat this what made you like
it I was like to be honest with you I
don't know but something about this is
[__] working and then from that I
transitioned it into uh eating sushi so
like sometimes when we see people who
um they don't like sushi I get it yeah
yeah I 100 get it like people are so
apologetic about it now they go oh I'm
sorry I don't like you say why are you
what you're sorry for bro yeah you just
was your [__] [__] ass all right I
get it you know [__] Nate Diaz 209
[__] you know what the [__] yeah dude
I didn't go like this I did inverted I
did like a book by the way I'm not
implying that Nate's like you know like
homo you know I always think of a homo
erectus he's looking from that era
sometimes he's a crow Magnum like food
is such a weird thing because like so if
you guys don't know years ago I did this
video where um
I showed you guys this thing called
little meets LA and little meets La was
actually it was Robin's thing and you
might have seen Robin in the video yeah
so I did a uh a private dinner thing uh
a couple of times at Robin's Place and
it was at that place called Lacey which
is the first time that we met so little
meets is was was super fun right and
honestly for me like it reminded me of a
space where you know sometimes when like
when chefs cook right in and then if
they're line Cooks the creativity part's
not a part of it they're they're a part
of a working machine and then you got to
see some of these chefs just kind of
flex their like creativity muscles
without having to open up a restaurant
yeah and they were do they're allowed to
do this where you could create a story
with food and everything else and I
[__] love that [__] and at this time
I was a fatty but nowhere near like like
a foodie like I didn't really know
anything about food I just whatever gate
put in my mouth it gave me diarrhea I
ate that [__] so when I started going
when I started coming over to Lacey and
I was like talking to like chefs and
people I was like oh I know that's how
that was made oh this is kind of
interesting and they kind of really
sparked this idea of like oh okay I
think I kind of like food a little more
than the average person right and then
that's what kind of little Meats did and
I really that's what I really liked
about it so I started throwing these
like oh I decided to do with this like
private dinner event thing with Robin in
conjunction with little meats and so
there was this guy this [__] loser
well okay uh to preface that uh and also
like a to be continued too but there's
definitely there were definitely more
than one losers that came through but
there was fire that came through too you
know a hundred percent
success rate and everything right yeah
you know he he kind of reminded me of of
the modern day social media food
influencer that happened to be in touch
with the kitchen you know what I mean
yeah and for sure I mean that like I
mean just on that note too I was so
interesting because at the time nobody
was really using Instagram to like
promote a business at the time you know
it was like there was the snobbyism of
that kind of you know filters and all of
that right and then it turned into what
it is now obviously but at some point in
that history of it all it was like huh
I wonder what it would be like to
cook for strangers like it's one thing
to cook for friends and friends friends
but then it's like I wonder what it's
like to cook for strangers right and
it's kind of an interesting thought
right because it's it's very truthful in
a way too is if it's whack No One's
Gonna show up right oh a hundred percent
right and then if it's pretty cool then
people are going to show up and then you
know
oh when it was when it was time to start
cooking for strangers it was always like
we were thinking about like
was obviously my idea but like quickly
like people got real excited and they
decided to kind of join in holy crap
this whole time I was so high I was
[__] looking at you in a metaverse
and now I'm looking straight at you Dave
okay I'm back
okay so I had little Meats when I first
started it was like I was so curious
like what is it like to be able to like
serve strangers
and like strangers are gonna be honest
you're going to want to know like if
they like it or not right
but like
cooking for strangers is like
weird right because you know when you're
just when we have like our like potlucks
and our things right it's always just
like it happens naturally we're all like
kind of a part of it and we start
cooking food or like we start like let's
say it's a pot like everybody brings
food and like everybody's like sitting
and enjoying it but because we already
have a relationship with each other it's
a natural progress right yeah yeah yeah
yeah then to have dinner with somebody
who is [__]
you don't know them so what are you
gonna do if you don't know a person like
you come it's like this weird kind of
nervous energy and like at the time I
wanted to use Instagram as like an
advertising way right to like get people
to like know what's going on with it but
for me the most important part was like
the actual experience itself
that was the longest [__] explanation
for just one [__] sentence of
information thank God we have a little
bit more time to talk about my [__]
but basically that's what I wanted to
say no but like that's what little Meats
was right I think like there was just
there was this huge like
um
there's like a disconnect with with the
consumer and the person who's creating
the food like when it comes to like
modern food right now right and even to
the point now where you know everybody
is just looking for content and you
don't even know if they really like or
dislike the food yeah and even when they
say they dislike it I'm not even sure if
they dislike it anymore like I don't
know what the truth is right and I could
always say this by
like for example like you know with with
my wife whenever she cooks something
right I ask her where did you get that
recipe she goes I saw it on Tick Tock I
was like cool don't feed me yeah yeah
right yeah yeah yeah yeah without fail
every time she fed me a Tick-Tock video
food trash they don't care there's no r
d process to this it's just oh this is a
hot item let me just cook it so it looks
good on video and let me show you I'm
not sure if it tastes really good yeah
yeah and that's what happens all the
time well like what little Meats did
really well it connected the chef with
the food and you got to actually talk to
the chef because the chef was serving
you yep you know what I mean and it
really was Omakase yeah right like
you're not there's no like hiding behind
a waiter server of like 100 people this
is like 20 people in a room the chef is
telling you this is how I made this this
is the background story do you like this
yes or no now look me in the [__] eye
when you say it too you know yeah yeah
yeah and then the cool thing about that
too and this is like for all people who
do Yelp right everybody's a [__]
expert in food when none of you have
[__] picked up a pan in your life I
don't want to hear that [__] but um that
you could sit there and the chef could
be like okay this is how I developed
this dish and what it would do was give
a better experience to us yeah yeah for
sure and I think that's what was missing
a lot and you know also too with like
you know the way American dining is it's
here's your dish cool make sure can you
take this off do this modify that there
is no this is how the chef intended it
yeah you know for sure and little Meats
was different yeah it was like oh you're
here for a food experience yeah yeah I'm
not gonna change this part of the film
the film is shot yeah yeah the movie's
done you know beginning middle and it's
done we're not taking out a scene
because you don't like it yeah you don't
have to sit and watch the movie yeah
yeah for sure you know and that's what
you did really well
um obviously like there was like there
was like I forgot what the [__] I ate
but if you guys know another backstory
the you know my my soft serve where I
met this piece of [__] [__] uh I
actually met him at little meets and
mind you food wise the guy was good yeah
he's definitely had his moments for sure
yeah but he's a piece of [__] [__]
and if I ever see you on the middle
middle of the [__] streets I'm
gutting you like a [__] fish just
know that by the way he started up a
YouTube channel I saw it on my Facebook
I have half a mind to [__] send
everybody there to [__] you up but
inshallah brother
it's
you know everybody kind of has like a
good intention
and I also believe that they have good
intentions right and then it quickly
goes south the moment that like money
gets involved and then ego yeah ego and
then practicality and then you know just
also thinking big picture
that would definitely uh lack that his
ego was so [__] big for no [__]
reason like it was kind of like for me
Chef has to for sure have a bit of it
yeah for sure and you know for me like
one of the he was a really good life
lesson for me right because for me I I
think I chased a lot of art right but
when you're trying to create a business
there's there has to be a good medium
between both right because you're still
trying to sell a product yeah but you
just don't have to sell your soul for
the per se this [__] didn't
understand any of that [__] yeah like
the one of the biggest signs and I
remember the first time I ever walked in
and I was like hey this is what's gonna
happen in the first month that I'm with
your business I'm gonna see what's going
on with this and I'm gonna Market it I'm
going to rework your branding and then
we're gonna shift this right did a great
job on it I saw this full serve a
customer
customer comes up they go hey what do
you have he goes you don't see the sign
you can't read
I was like
what the [__] are you
sure he goes what the size right it
doesn't [__] matter they're paying
customer they didn't come here to
[__] hear your lip he was definitely
admitted though he definitely was
somebody who would admit though that
he's a piece of [__] around people 100
you know you could acknowledge that you
know what I mean like being a piece of
[__] by yourself in your room in front
of your friends is different than when
somebody who has invested I didn't
invest that was a I was uh I had Sweat
Equity right pending on my performance
got it so just to put it in perspective
right that [__] place was making 50 a
week on average yeah before I redid
everything right and then went from
fifty dollars a [__] weeks so
starting from like September all the way
to December I think they gross like 200k
yeah so I earned my [__] right to
that person of course you know first so
I did that this guy squanders everything
okay
you know like comes to did I ever tell
you this [__] so this guy
walks up and we're at a meeting and this
is the first month since I rebranded
it's [__] pack there yeah he goes I
remember every time I would go to Aqua
Grill I'd always see the spot it was
always packed this full [__] left the
Coachella for a whole weekend and left
the staff without telling them
and then comes back and I'm like where
the [__] are I'm heated you know what I
mean and then nobody knows what to do
how to run the store because he didn't
train people properly yeah yeah yeah no
communication we're at um Hyundai right
and I'm [__] heated but I'm calming
myself down and I see him walking to the
restaurant this fool has [__] beads
and [__] on his deck [__] sunglasses
on oh yeah like straight from straight
from Coachella and I sit there yeah yeah
and I'm like you [__] out of your
mind yeah yeah yeah he goes well I was
like I thought they could handle and I
[__] slammed this [__] beer wow
busted and I was like are you [__]
out of your mind and I was he I'm a lot
better now yeah yeah but it was the idea
that this guy abandoned his staff for a
weekend without telling them and I was
like what in what world did you think
this was okay appreciate it and then
from then on out you know him like when
somebody confronts him like on some real
[__] he gets hyper avoided so he would
Dodge me
24 7 and he would go to the other
partners to talk to them to talk to me
yeah yeah and I'm like that's not how I
roll like I'll find you you know there's
always
I don't know like I'm assuming it's
obviously every people group but I can
only say like
maybe around Korean Americans in LA
but like
there always seems like there's a few of
them who are just like
I do believe they have good intentions
but then they're just out and out just
frauds in a way like yeah I don't know
if Fraud's the right word but
something not good something in which uh
a lot of lies are involved a lot of
shadiness
um I guess maybe that's just somebody
who just might have drug habits though
too right yeah I mean that [__]
he he had crazy drug habits you know in
his mind and his life and like for me
like I think because like I got to know
him as a friend first I never got to see
him in a business aspect right yeah yeah
and I just believed in the product and I
believe what he could do and mind you
the softer was tasty yeah yeah um there
were certain things I disagreed with it
sure because obviously for me because
when I don't know something I ask people
who do know something I mean he was the
type of person where if he knew that
everybody loved it he would destroy it
yes yes yes and
not in an unpredictable way but in such
a predictable way that it's like then
are you really an artist I know that's
an abstract way of thinking but that's
kind of the way that I looked at that
that's um like in terms of like
that person's like
self idea of like what an artist is and
how you should live that out right yeah
yeah maybe in his idea as crazy as it
sounds it's like people have done that
before but maybe with more pure
intentions yeah and I think like the
hard part with working with him was like
one of the things I don't like is
dishonesty right I don't care about
mistakes because everybody [__] up you
know this is that's the part about
running a business you know and things
would [__] up at the at the at the
business right yeah yeah and then other
people because they were so trusting of
his quote unquote expertise yeah they
would never ask him questions but then
for me you know I'm speaking confidently
gets you a long way in life yes
especially around other Asian Americans
yes and he would be like Oh I'm the chef
person I ran a crew of This I know
everything and they would just trust
everything he says problem with me is
like I'm 10 of you I research a lot of
things and so when things wouldn't work
just one quick little Google search that
I'm like hey how come this and this
isn't working why didn't you replace
this he goes we don't need that I'm like
no it's not working and then all of a
sudden I was like okay cool like for
example like we had this uh Nitro cold
brew thing right and it wasn't putting
Nitro into the [__] cold brew so it
didn't have the foam and the froth which
is why people like that yeah for sure
and then he goes that's how it's
supposed to be
again let's say the checklist of items
of okay like I don't know I'm not in the
food world like how my friends who are
in the food world are in the food world
but you know that that one dude that
sexy dude would like to Jesus hair yeah
yeah yeah he's like has that cigarette
in his mouth right
whoever that [__] is I bet you
he might have even had this checklist
and he might have been the first guy I
don't know I'm just making the [__] out
but like doing something that's on that
list of like things that uh
a good Chef artiste or a legend is gonna
do you know what I mean
um that's another thing on that list
he's like that guy you know
and I think two
I was a little naive in the sense of
like I always want to think the best of
of your friends you know this is where
we had okay but this is where we had a
relationship but it wasn't as close
enough where you would have felt
comfortable saying to me
because yeah because I didn't really
know you like that exactly yeah and then
also like you know for me too is this
like you think oh it's like um
like those types like like that type of
person right the the point of why he was
at little meets was so that he could
move on to something bigger of course
there was a time where I was always
trying to find like a partner or people
who were like yeah yeah you know and I
think that's where his mentality was
trying to go
um but the goal is always to get them to
move to the next steps in life right
because who am I to like you know give
them advice on whatever whatever in
whatever industry Right restaurant
industry stuff but [__] what was I
talking about my close friend's
restaurant friends being hardcore oh
yeah the checklist and all of that stuff
um
no no wait we were talking about the oh
us talking about
um
like you know we I've said this to you
before I'm like damn dude I wish you
[__] talk to me first I know you know
but again we didn't have that type of
relationship I get it but even for me
when people who knew who he was
knew me
they went out on a limb not just like
one or two people like maybe three four
people
said hey I just want to let you know
like I I've seen you've been hanging
around Jay like on social media right so
before I had brought him in to kind of
do what we were going to do with what we
were doing in little means was I
I said hey
this isn't gonna be something where
I'm not gonna let you do something
with me and little Meats
like I'm all about giving people chances
in life
but I do want to know though that or I
do want to let you know that that
doesn't mean I'm going to go into this
naively giving you 100 Trust on
everything yeah
so
I kept it pretty simple I said not even
a dollar not even a reimbursement
do I want you doing anything money
related because the things that I had
heard were money and responsibility
related things
so
I had this conversation from day one
this is probably why I was actually one
of the only people maybe who's worked
with him and I say works because all
volunteers like literally just a passion
project right it is
[Music]
um
I wanted him to know what I know about
him but I wanted to give him a chance so
just what they also didn't want to give
him yeah any opportunity to
um but then fast forward though he he he
did cross those boundaries with uh other
people yeah
um
who were part of the little meets
project yeah you know so see that's the
thing too like
the people that I was partnered with
right they gave him full Reign on
everything yeah yeah and one of the
biggest tells evidently gets you far yes
one of the biggest tell signs that I had
even before the other stuff where he was
already avoiding me yeah he would be
like oh I accidentally used the credit
card for my private dinners for the from
our from our soft service yeah yeah
there was a couple instances where
somehow some way
because we still had open accounts with
certain vendors like food vendors
after
gone there was a time where
suddenly suddenly there was a credit
card charge and I was like huh and then
when I confronted him about it he was
like oh shoot like I I thought it was uh
going on a different card or whatever
this and that so it is what it is
obviously I got to charge back whatever
but
you know I'm sure he still got his
inventory though oh 100 that's what I'm
saying and then you know he was like oh
I accidentally I was like no you don't
accidentally do [__] like that you know
what I mean and you know for me growing
up like there's a few things that you
just never do right especially the
friends you don't [__] my girl you don't
steal money from me those are death
sentences you know what I mean like I've
literally seen people get their teeth
knocked out for that [__] yeah and in my
mind I'm like I'm an adult right and I
don't do these things I'm also not a
thug but I was going to [__] him up but
then you know as an adult we're like
this is we're running a business I have
a future ahead of me and I think it's
also a reputation too it's reputation
you know and so you know these things
got really and then I think what
happened was would because you know I
have a reputation of being just a little
you know very hyper honest and so you
know I'm talking to the partner
something what are you guys doing like
this is ridiculous yeah like you need to
set boundaries and figure this stuff out
oh no no no no no like he and you know I
got really upset with them because they
started protecting him from me and they
started lying to me and I was like now
you guys are all [__] so yeah uh again
you know I was saying in different
pockets of this I'm just gonna say Asian
American for Asian American fake is
these pockets of these Asian American
circles even like let's say Church
crowds or whatever there's always
of this person
like uh you know everybody knows it's
actually in my opinion I think it's
actually very difficult to tell the
truth in life like I don't know about
you but like or I can't speak for
anybody else but for me
when I wake up in the morning I have to
consciously tell myself don't be a liar
and even sometimes and we talked about
this one time where like I'm like gonna
be a liar till the day that I die I just
feel that like I am
but when that happens
I feel terrible and then I'll go out of
my way and actually apologize after the
fact and acknowledge what I did was a
lie
and then try to basically ask for
forgiveness for that particular person
right I mean it sounds like a Christian
mold right I'm not Christian but uh it's
very similar in this idea where I
I always know that I'm going to lie
if I don't think about it like my
autopilot human self like it's just you
know it's just [__] freestyle like
Eminem it could be like a freestyle lie
about something to just convenience me
you know so I have to think about that
all the time uh which when I do I'm
successful and I'm very happy about that
but it still happens to me so on that
note like I always feel like within the
circle of people
there's like a template of these like
compulsive lying people who never fess
up to what they've done wrong they
always have an excuse and look I I know
what that feels like because I know what
it feels like at a younger age you know
and I've talked to you about this where
um
bring the Michael close so bring the mic
in front of your mouth like this
um okay earlier
also my apologies dude earlier I was so
high okay I couldn't even focus on like
three words after what I said oh you're
high right now and I'm a little drunk so
it's all good sorry guys I swear if you
powered through up until this point
a little better you know because like I
like that subject of like Lion right
yeah you know and I've talked about this
a lot where
when I was a kid like my dad used to
beat the [__] out of me for like right
yeah I'm talking about beat the living
[__] out of me right and because my dad
hated lying because he's had a history
of people who lied to him in his life
yeah and because that is stuck with him
it scarred him yeah yeah so when we
would lie as kids my dad would always be
like look anything that you do don't you
ever [__] lie to me yeah because you
could he goes even if the punishment is
me whooping your ass you should live
your life like an honest person yeah and
be mad about this [__] and don't lie but
I would lie and he would see it in my
eyes yeah yeah he would beat the [__]
[__] out of me yeah so when I was a kid
like one of the things that always stuck
with me with him was
if does that ever make you into a better
liar
it didn't it made me it made me too
honest okay that's okay because somehow
it might sometimes go the other way
though right I couldn't navigate got it
got it you know and so for me
I became like this
albeit like I'm I learned later on in
life that there's a fine line between
being honest and being an [__] yeah
but I didn't know the difference right
because I would always have this fear
that if I'm lying that I was going to
hell yeah you know because my dad
instilled this in me yeah so when I
would like like for example if somebody
came up like hey what do you think about
this outfit I'm like that [__] sucks
yeah you know and I would just leave it
at that yeah yeah but I would never
think about like the emotional
repercussions of the things that you say
whether because it's true or not and
there's sometimes you just don't need to
say something at all I didn't know what
that [__] was and so my whole life I was
going through this fear of like if I lie
I'm a if I don't lie I'm a better person
for that yeah yeah but I would never
think about the ripple effect that it
would have when sometimes the truth not
everybody's ready for that [__] right
and just because you tell the truth all
the time doesn't mean that you're a good
person sometimes you're just a [__]
[__] and so yeah it definitely
depends on it's also intention for sure
yeah you know and for me like I had to
learn how to navigate these things right
and we talked about this off podcast
where there's an awkward situation
between a couple who got yeah and I have
to learn how to play cordial because it
affects other people if I'm not yeah you
know is that technically kind of lying
yeah I guess but I have to look at
bigger picture things and I never did
that before yeah yeah but then it got
into a point where when I came on this
space right when I started becoming a
standard community at the age of 16.
like
I I was people were telling me like
sometimes you just got to learn how to
lie a little better and I just wasn't
very good at it because it felt like my
my spirit and my soul was being eaten up
yeah yeah yeah right and so I used to
get in trouble that trouble right but it
was like there were things that I hated
because I would be on like my Channel or
you know my other friend's Channel JK
news yeah and I'm telling these stories
but I have to change certain aspects of
it so people wouldn't it wouldn't go
back to people that I knew yeah yeah but
I was so bad at [__] lying I started
fumbling over my words as I'm trying to
change like 30 of the story yeah yeah
and in a way you're gonna get um what is
that fact check too because you get a
bigger platform exactly and I know that
30 of this story is a lot right only
because I don't want it to go back to
that person yeah and I'm because I'm so
bad at this [__] yeah I'm like like okay
I guess I shouldn't say this name okay
let me change this part of the story
because it's too similar to this this
part in this part yeah and then after a
while I just didn't give a [__] anymore
I'm like this whole [__] right here is
[__] me up I'm just gonna say it and
the one thing I'm Gonna Change is just
the name got it because now at least
I'll I'll I'll be consistent because
that was the hardest part right because
and it happened from one conversation
yeah or one story that I told on the JK
news episode it went back to that person
their feelings were hurt yeah it made me
feel terrible
this podcast is brought to you by better
help my friends if you don't know what
better help is better help is online
therapy Getting to Know Yourself can be
a lifelong process especially because
we're always growing and changing you
want to be better than the person that
you were the day before even if it's
just a little bit therapy is all about
deepening your self-awareness and
understanding because sometimes we don't
know what we want or why we react the
way that we do until we talk through
things better help connect you with the
licensed therapists who can take you on
that journey to self-discovery from
wherever you are mental health is
something that's very important to me
and something that I'm working on every
day and if I'm focusing on my physical
health I'm focusing on my mental health
as well if you're thinking of starting
therapy give better help but try it's
entirely online designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with the
licensed therapist and switch therapists
anytime for no additional charge
discover your potential with better help
visit betterhelp.com genius today to get
10 off your first month that's
betterhelp help help.com genius
yeah yeah yeah right yeah it didn't
matter if the whole world didn't know
who they were but they knew yeah and
then now I just was like you know what
guys [__] deal with it I'm all we're
[__] mid-30s like who the [__] cares
yeah and the friends who are gonna stay
friends with you are going to stay
friends with you and then maybe arguably
to a certain degree the ones who don't
want to be friends with you after that
for that reason that's probably somebody
that you don't really care to be friends
with either yeah and sometime soonly on
the topic of like being honest like you
know when I would tell some of these
stories like some of these people think
that you're lying about the stories that
you tell because they haven't lived your
life and because they're like oh because
I didn't do it there's no way you could
have done it it's like
that's a logical fallacy right like that
makes absolutely no [__] sense like
what you've experienced is what you've
experienced what I have is what I've
experienced unless you met me otherwise
there's no way you could deny what I'm
saying yeah this is this is what
happened if I told the story a million
times over and it was the same [__]
story yeah I guess I'm really consistent
with this lie over the past 10 years
sure you know and so like the honesty
route was always easy for me because my
dad says that at least even if you [__]
up at least you were honest when you
were doing it and you could lie and you
could die knowing that [__]
in my group of friends we have this uh
yeah these are arbitrary [__] numbers
not like real data but we try to act
like we're you know data driven yeah
yeah but like
there's like
Big Talk which everybody does okay like
maybe almost every guy does Big Talk
okay there's big talk and then there's
just flat outline yeah so if I had to
put a percentages if you will yeah up to
15 to 20 percent
is Big Talk
you know I don't know like let's say
like you were like doing the typical guy
talk where it was like my body count was
300 but then in actuality I don't know
let's say it was like 250.
I don't know is that is that math good
enough did that okay but whatever that
you know just again arbitrary numbers
but there's there's where it's like yeah
the point is is you're still somebody
who has a high body count and you're
proud of that right but then uh
whether it's 250 or 300 not a big
difference the point is
you are
a [__] yeah okay right
um versus
if a dude says
300 but then they've only been with
let's say 30 people
then that's a lie you know so that's
where that formula to me is just like
you know 75 is a total eye
right but then I guess the question is
is like where is that percentage from
you where that starts right yeah yeah
you know what I mean like I mean like
you know what especially in stand-up
comedy like you tell the story that's
the truth yeah but then you kind of make
it bigger and more like aggrandize to
make it funnier yeah yeah yeah right so
it's like what the big talk Big Talk 85
truth fifty percent you know extra
little splits yeah you know what I mean
yeah yeah and that's fine you know you
know growing up and being around people
who are honestly like habitual Liars it
always fascinated me because I'm like I
always think in my mind like what is
what is the end goal of this yeah right
what is the what is the purpose yeah
exactly what are you trying to intend to
do or like what is the laugh rooted in
let's say you're doing comedy stand up
and someone and the the people the core
of why people laughed so hard
that has to be factual like you know it
can't be you know yeah 100 and like when
you know meeting people who like I've
met now and look I'm a lot more tactful
in the way that I approach people right
and
but if somebody like blatantly lies to
me yeah or to the point where it creates
like like somebody lies to me to the
point where it could be damaging in the
future yeah like I have to say something
like there's no way I'm not going to
sure you know what I mean because like
I want people around me to be
somewhat honest at least yeah right of
course and like especially when you're
living like yourself because you're a
public profile in a lot of ways so it's
super important
you're probably around a lot of people
or not you're around but like if anybody
has a chance with you who's like who
doesn't know you they're going to be
tempted to be like a yes man to
everything yeah you know what I'm saying
versus like obviously that's the thing
like one of the people it's so funny you
mentioned that I had a conversation I
was talking to some really good friends
of mine yeah and you know I was telling
them that one of the type of people that
I hate the most yeah are highly
agreeable people and the reason why is
because those people are the most
dishonest human beings I've ever met in
my life okay so this is I love where
you're going with this because this is
obviously I mean we've talked about this
off camera but
this is the part where I'm really trying
to work hard on in my life oh and by the
way this is a good segue too because I
forgot that we were going to talk about
this like my man's been on shrooms right
and this has been something that I've
been relatively uh curious about only
because
um uh one of my buddies too he's been
unpacking a lot of traumatic [__] that's
going on with his life the passing of
his mom and a lot of the stuff that
happened to his you know family life
yeah and when we're talking about
honesty we're not only just talking
about honesty with other people we're
talking honestly to ourselves yeah
arguably even harder oh yeah right and
so
one of the things about me is that I
think like you know I'm always like my
worst critic and I'm also a little too
brutal with myself sometimes yeah yeah
so when I hear people go through this
thing where I think a majority of people
go through this thing where that that
honest conversation that they have with
themselves is very hard yeah right of
course
um and I feel like a couple of my
friends probably you included as well is
that shrooms does this thing where
you're where a mirror is put in front of
your face yeah like if if let's say like
people drink alcohol or do something
it's like in a way it's like to get away
and not have to think about your life
versus like
again like I'm not an expert obviously
as you know I'm like I'm not like you
know anybody else who talks about
psilocybin or whatever right but
definitely I can say that it makes you
focus on your life
if you'll allow it to in a way yeah and
that's where it's like the scary
monsters is sometimes it's because you
have to face the truth and it's always
easier to avoid things right
um I think anybody who's listening to
this podcast right now I'm right there
with you like
people ask this a lot about me I've
always openly spoke about this I suffer
from social anxiety like a [__]
yeah like my social anxiety is crazy
like to the point where I was a kid I
couldn't order food from people I got
you I couldn't walk up to a [__] like
Carl's Jr yeah and order from the
[__] register because my social
anxiety was crippling yeah
well I got to a point where I was just
like you know what like you gotta just
[__] do this [__] right you gotta
face this stuff yeah and from somehow
that transition to be doing stand-up
because it was like if anything that I
was going to do that was going to hold
me back from something yeah I just kind
of faced it head on yeah it didn't
matter what the [__] it was it was like
okay you can't you have social anxiety
guess what you're gonna try public
speaking yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
exactly and so yeah that fear is what I
think a lot of people try to confront
when they do the psychedelics because
for sure all my friends who have done it
and I literally mean all uh not just
like one who just enjoyed the trip but
didn't really
get anything out of it yeah but also you
can have like you know there's all this
like science and data that's like coming
out more of the woodwork the data and
science has been there for kind of like
for some time to a certain degree right
but because it was like driven so
underground right and again like
you know I saw a bunch of YouTube what
the [__] do I know right but like you
know
where everybody says is like you know
this part and then the Reagan
Administration and then whatever
whatever this happened fast forward to
just now things are starting to kind of
be okay to come out of the woodwork
right yeah people who like
had done them in their past and you know
it's it's been a net positive in their
life and stuff that wouldn't be
something that you would put on paper
because of the implications of what that
might be right so that world is changing
right and so
yeah it's
for me like it's it's weird because
going back to kind of like the the lying
and lying to yourself
um
if you can't get that part figured out
like
you should never be an influential
person on someone's life or how they
should live their life uh does it make
you feel like you're a fraud of course
you know because like and that's the
thing right is like
I've committed my sins like
I've done so many terrible things you
know as like narcissistic as
self-preserving as it's ever been like
you know selfish [__] you know
um
and that's something that's like
so disgusting but it's also like in my
nature to a certain degree you know
um I'm not saying like every single
person but definitely me it's in my
nature and so
having to look at myself constantly and
then wanting to be able to then be able
to be like a positive
a net positive to like people or like
Society like
little meets is a perfect example
the idea of it
was so amazing
you know hints of Robin genius as you
know like
themat activity your podcast you know
these moments of Genius where yeah
that's awesome you know like an
authentic place where people can express
themselves culinarily but also people
can come and people who are passionate
about food can enjoy that right
but I was a terrible person during that
time and when I say that is is like
let's say the shadiest I could have ever
been in my life and not like
business-wise uh relationally I was such
a terrible [__] person you know and
then I had this like silver Club where
like it was genuinely people were
getting good and amazing things about it
and like you know I [__] love those
days those are awesome right and I go
through these weird phases in life where
like I'm just curious and then I'll
[__] go start a supper club in front
of a bunch of strangers because I'm just
I want to answer some questions and
because I'm just curious about that you
know like what's it like to to serve a
bunch of strangers you know like yeah
it's one thing like when your homies are
gonna come over and your friends come
over and your friends friends come over
because hey free food good food who's
not going to want to come to that but
that good food though is not a
requirement free food is usually and
people are always going to say and
because it's free they're gonna kind of
lie to you and say like you know it's
good but like you know it's like that um
[__]
um what's that
talent show or the small town you know
uh oh yeah anything any talent show
where like the small town they hear a
bunch of people telling them oh dude
you're so great you're so amazing you
know you hear all these amazing things
and then they perform in front of you
know people who are going to tell them
the truth and it's very painful right
same thing like food wise like I was
like
man like I love food I'm not a chef but
I wonder if like I can recreate like
maybe what restaurants were originally
intended to be like a place where
people
like
would serve food but then it wasn't just
food right it was like you know like
there was like oh it's like Supper Club
show food and it was like a whole night
you know going out right
um
I always wondered like can that kind of
hint of that culture come back in that
modern world right I'm not like the
first person to do it obviously but it's
just I just wanted to know for myself
could I cook for people have them also
cover their cost for it though and be
happy with all of that time spent with
it you know yeah um anyways sorry I kind
of went off on a tangent but we were
kind of talking initially about
lying yeah yeah and you're talking about
you felt during this time in your life
you're very selfish and
yeah super selfish in that part of my
life so for me like but even before that
I guess
trying to tie that point I think earlier
I don't remember exactly what I said but
um
for me I find priority in trying to tell
the truth even when
I consider lying like staying silent
about something you know telling that
person that you know dude your dish
sucked you know
um but in the best intention of saying
let's make it better right
um you know so you know on that note
like I you know I I
but I found this recently out about
myself right having a conversation with
a friend
where
he's an engineer so he reads things
we're talking about mushrooms my bad
yeah we were talking about mushrooms and
he was talking about this where he was
like
you know
I have a very certain theme about people
who I tend to get closer to whether it's
instantly or later on right
and it's a very specific mentality and
he was telling me like you tend to
gravitate towards people who are only
about like seven percent of people on
this Earth and he was like he was
reading the study about human beings and
he goes the 90 of the other I don't know
the exact number but let's use these
arbitrary numbers right 93 at seven
percent 93 of people in this case study
was done right they are people who are
likely more so let's say for example we
go into the food example right and most
people who are probably listeners
probably know that you probably fall
into this category it's not a bad thing
it means you're the normal one you're 93
of the world
somebody Cooks you food right or let's
say I cook food I cook food and I'm the
other 93 I'm the 93 that when I cook
food I want you to say that you like it
or something positive about it even if
you don't like it and if you say that
you don't like it I think that you're
being rude to me and you're an [__]
yeah that's 93 of the world because you
can't handle the truth yeah versus the
other seven percent which is the
category that I'm in and a lot of
friends who I really like are in it is
we cook food you eat it and you go oh I
don't really like this then we go oh
well let me try to make something else
for you sure and then let me try to
adjust this what don't you like about
this for sure for sure and that's only
seven percent of the world yeah yeah
yeah but my lens and my view of the
world is that oh I thought this is how
everybody is I was like no no no we're
actually in the small amount yeah and I
didn't know that yeah yeah and when he
showed me the study and I'll bring it up
later on where I was like holy [__] this
whole time I assume people
like
were more like me and they're not where
I feel like if I cook something and then
somebody was like he's a little tough
you could have done this and that I'm
like oh [__] you're right maybe I'll do
that next time most people are like I
can't believe you said that like I
cooked this for you I did all this work
and you're gonna say this to me yeah
yeah I'm like oh and that's when my wife
told me she goes I've never had it hurt
like but that is you you are that you're
that person where you'll make a
cheesecake seven [__] times even
though six times people told you it was
good yeah yeah you know yeah yeah yeah
yeah of course of course so yeah you
know that's kind of like dude I just
want to know the data stop telling me I
like it okay
just to to make a better cheesecake for
you yeah I want to know the truth yeah
yeah yeah yeah and then go back to tying
the the Callback of uh you know you hate
[__] people who are going to be too
focused on being the nice person always
you know what I mean yeah and agreeable
people tend to be very
um dishonest and also very self selfish
and what I mean by that is that there's
somebody that's in my life that I know
that's a very agreeable person now on
the surface area a lot of people didn't
understand within my groups like what
exactly don't you like they're always
happy and they're always smiling and
they're always nice yeah I was like
because it's dishonest yeah yeah because
when they're not happy I can sense it
but here in their smiles yeah yeah and I
would say and they asked me what was the
first time you felt that about them yeah
I've known this person for four or five
months and every time they talk to me
they greet me like they met me for the
first time and what I mean by that it's
very it's almost industry-like where
it's like how are you how have you been
yeah we've been friends for four [__]
months you should never great be like
that and you know they kind of sat there
and they thought they were like oh I see
what you're saying I was like it's
almost like they live in this Truman
World where they can't handle the fact
that there's somebody that might dislike
them and so everything that they say is
catered to what they think I like but
they don't know me so I know they're
lying yeah yeah yeah so being around
that person's all also very dishonest
and what I found out is that because I
tend to be a little bit more on the
truthful side sometimes to a fault than
when I would speak to them about
opinions that was disagreeable they
would go home and they would cry yeah
yeah and I'm like wait hold on but every
time you saw me you were smiling sure
you could have talked to me about that
and then I could have adjusted a little
bit and then we could have worked this
out but that person who's so agreeable
can't fathom the idea that somebody
dislikes them yeah and so you end up
inherently being a dishonest person for
sure you know yeah it's
it always again it goes back to like if
we just focus on like being truthful
um
and this is where I draw my line to a
certain degree right if I don't have a
relationship with that person even then
sometimes I'll be truthful but it's more
just because I want to be a dick right
uh you know what I mean but like
if if I don't know the person and I
don't really have an invested time with
that person then there I can see maybe
just not saying something right
um but because you know like I want to
be a dick and because also sometimes you
know I also want to just say hey maybe
like you know here's something that like
somebody everybody else is thinking
but has nobody ever said to you you know
that's a
you know uh also like you know with
shaky fun in of itself you know like and
yeah you know what I mean like uh but
anyways like
focusing on being truthful is is
definitely uh is my priority hopefully
till the day that I die is that what the
shrooms did for you or is that something
that you've been struggling with for a
while I mean you know
like I mean in a lot of ways right like
we even first started talking remember
that time when we FaceTime about like
during the George Floyd stuff oh that's
right yeah yeah because like you know
like obviously like I didn't live in
K-Town but like I'm old enough where I
was during their LA riots 100 right and
obviously like the church that I went to
like you know half those rooftop Koreans
were like [__] cheap sign names at
like the church you know at Young not
Church you know so you know the
[__] you know with the fishing
and I'll buy you know casual shooting
[__] anyway so like that was like when I
saw that I like
I was like scared like I was not scared
uh there's like some kind of untreated
Yeah well yeah and then more than the
average person like uh because like you
know like I saw that happen before I
also have like friends
and their families who are still like
basically poor because of that era
because you know whatever their
businesses got burned down right but
anyways we started talking that's when
we first started talking like kind of
more yeah yeah yes right that was our
first conversation that was like the
kick off the pandemic that was yeah I
didn't even think about it yeah so like
think about that that's like that first
time where like we actually like kind of
had a combo you know and it was also two
right because it's also because I know
that you're like
you have a footprint in the Asian
American Community obviously yeah uh and
so a part of me was like also at the
same time like and I always struggle at
this right and you know I always joke
about it in the most forms of like even
like Korean Supremacy right
I don't mean Korean Supremacy like a
white supremacist Korean supremacist I
mean Korean Supremacy as just being
Korean
kimchi you know what I mean
um anyways uh
you know like it's like
I always grew up where I was either I
was always thought like politically like
you know I was never political I don't
think I am now either but like I always
thought of myself as like shoot like I
always had this like idea I'm like man
when like rich white people and
conservatives want to use like the Asian
Community
um for one thing
uh to you know the model minority right
and then and then flip that back over to
like uh
you know like let's say the black
community is like
you know for us we are the minor model
minority myth in a lot of ways but you
know like we're pawns base basically is
like I feel like I felt like a lot of
times growing up like I always felt like
the Asian American Community we're
always Pawns of other races like oh 100
you know what I mean yeah yeah but it's
so crazy right like we're like the
biggest population in the world right
um
and like obviously you know not in the
United States but like it's it's just
interesting like we have our own unique
story too you know like we understand
obviously the the hardships of being
like a minority in the sense of like you
know coming over as immigrants and
things like that or parents generation
or whatever
but then we also like super duper duper
duper like want to like financially
succeed and you know like start families
and you know whatever you know the
typical nuclear thing right too right
there's like you know there's always
like that constant like
I think you know the hard part too for a
lot I think for this younger generation
right and you know a lot of people in
our age bracketed group
you know sometimes they [__] on the
younger generation a lot yeah their
biggest struggle now is that
they have like identity is the biggest
talk in the last like five or six years
right and you know sometimes when I have
a conversation about this they don't
understand why I don't care right and
what I mean by that it's not that I
don't care about what you're going
through yeah is that
um I don't ever need to think about my
identity because I know who I am yeah
and I don't need to care if somebody
else knows yeah you just be who you are
exactly and so when I say that I I'll
tie it into entertainment right yeah or
they go oh like you rep for us Asians I
actually don't I actually rep for myself
and my asian-ness comes out because I am
Asian exactly yeah you know what I mean
it's a byproduct of everything that I've
grown up with yeah I don't talk about my
love for [__] kimchi being the best
[__] accoutrement to any type of meat
on this world because it's the cool
thing to say I do it because I've eaten
it my whole [__] life you know what I
mean so the the Asian the Korean
supremacy of me comes out because it's
just who I am yeah yeah you know what I
mean and I think when this younger
generation gets to truly understand that
right like you can work on your own
excellence and understand that a part of
your Excellence is also your Asian
identity that helped build this part of
who you are life becomes a little easier
it becomes less about your gen your that
gender your identity politics right and
so you know during this time like a lot
of people I have felt their frustrations
because I did understand it's like every
time something bad would happen right
it's like well how come you Asians are
standing up for us aren't you a minority
got it we're there for you that we go
through stuff hey we're going through
bigger problems your problems don't
matter so it's like okay well what the
[__] do you want from us now you know
what I mean so at that point I'm not
saying [__] everybody exactly I'm saying
exactly focus on it let's focus on our
community right because at this point
we're like
bowing down to the white man right and
then we're trying to Ally with with this
with with like uh BLM right which is not
a bad thing but if you want to talk
about your identity right
and your identity is constantly bowing
down to everybody else begging for them
to protect your culture that is your
responsibility you can do that you can
you can support other cultures yeah but
you also have to uplift your own for
sure you know what I mean yeah yeah and
so I think sometimes with like Asian
Americans like the hardest part that
they have to do deal with is that even
when we try to carve our Asian American
identity we try to do it in the style of
how other people do it yeah you know
what I mean yeah yeah for sure like it's
like
when they you know that obviously
doesn't fit because of all of the
nuances in every single culture exactly
like there's you know there was um
uh black lives matter and then we had
yellow Peril why
like that was from like the 80s or
something right why move on from that
[__] we didn't have to go ahead and add
our own tag we got our own [__] thing
going on here yeah you know what I mean
and sometimes I feel like the kids who
talk about Asian pride the most you guys
are the ones who are actually ashamed of
your culture the most that you're trying
to make it as white packaged as possible
when you don't [__] have to for sure
you know what I mean every [__] food
video that I see on Instagram is always
somebody doing a stupid ass [__]
voice over how much you hated being
Asian when you were a kid like
what is this [__] you know what I mean
and you're not doing it because it's an
important story to hear you're doing it
because it gets you views I mean it's
most people are boring you know what I
mean so I understand yeah and so again
you know I always sound like I'm the
apologist for everybody you know what I
mean but like you know it's like I also
get it like man if you're boring then
you know you're gonna I don't know like
movie reference I'm [__] old like
American Beauty I don't know I remember
the scene where like [__] you know
Kevin Spacey you know rest in peace
um you know he uh Kevin Spacey just died
you just reminded me right now no he
he's not no he's not dead Oh I thought
you said rest in peace no no I mean like
rest in peace like he was like one of
the OG cancellations you know what I
mean rest in peace like I meant like
sorry um you know like uh you know
uh him and you know he's trying to hook
up with like you know his daughter's uh
daughter's friend you know this bunker
and then at you know at some point like
she says like I'm a virgin he's like oh
and then you know they're like they they
stop and then and then and then she was
like
she's like her biggest fear was to ever
be boring you know and like when you
know then like Kevin Spacey says
something like oh you're uh you know
boring is the last thing you could ever
be or whatever and then she's like yeah
there's nothing worse than being boring
you know
um
the apologist in me whenever I see those
videos and I'm like it's so cringe
you're so painful where I'm like you
know like the snobbiness in me kicks in
or just just because I know that that's
just not the right thing to do in terms
of like let's say cooking or food or
that's not gonna taste good right it's
uh
it's boring man you gotta make yourself
look not boring but the thing about that
is too it's okay to be boring yeah true
like once again people who are great
entertainers they are the outliers you
know what I mean yeah yeah there is
nothing wrong with being boring yeah
yeah and to be honest with you most
people are yeah and because you guys are
boring you guys allow entertainers to do
what they [__] do you don't have to
like when they go hey guys I just want
to tell you what I did this morning
nobody [__] cares yeah yeah
yeah we don't have to [__] know and
then I asked somebody I was like oh you
want to make a living off of this he's
like no this is just I feel like this is
the thing that no you don't have to do
anything I don't need to know about the
ham sandwich that you had at the gas
station yeah yeah yeah for sure you know
what I mean yeah but you know the fatty
in me will I eat it for free probably
yeah 100 you know and so you know you
know going on to another tangent to it
like
but we definitely got to bring it back
to mushrooms though because I definitely
want to share some stuff that I've been
going for sure for sure but for sure
yeah when we always talk about food like
it's not on a level of snobbery like I
eat everything and anything yeah you
know what I mean yeah yeah yeah what I
don't I I actually think that people who
create food content who don't care about
food they're actually the snobs because
they want to be this knowledge and
[__] portal for what is good and
what's hot that's snobbery to me that
that template works if you're using real
data and science yeah right so like for
example is if you're like scientifically
almost like you know lab coat style like
searing a steak where you make the
ultimate like crust and Sear
for sure like you know what I mean like
uh you can talk about like you know like
uh sorry the point I'm trying to say is
when you make something good you are
definitely the type of person where you
want to know why it's good yeah you know
what I mean uh every everybody who cooks
or cares about it right they're always
Gonna Wanna Know The why because that
variable is under control you know what
I mean like that's uh
I mean that's I I feel like that's like
the thing that's we share in common
right it's like that okay it's like oh
like when I was your scientists I value
how about this I value I [__] value
science thank you scientists I can never
be one well if you guys want to know why
I'm [__] sewing the tomatoes it's
because this [__] face like I yeah
failed my tomatoes last year because
there was a crazy heat wave of like a
hundred and something degrees Yeah you
gave me his beautiful little transplants
and then this heat wave happened it was
they were growing beautifully 120
degrees for [__] two three weeks
obliterated them they weren't strong
enough to survive it yeah and I got so
sad you know what though what's dope
about it is I mean at the same time
also like you know me I love trying to
find out and do as much research before
I start like a project again it's not
like a big project that has to do with
money it's just you know like I want to
grow tomatoes right so I want to take it
seriously so I want to learn about it as
much as I can right my goal before I
start anything that I want to try to get
better at or learn is I try to learn all
of the [__] ups and know why the
fuck-ups happen because I already know
I'm gonna [__] it up right so like for
even me last year was like my first
season of growing tomatoes right and
I was like as weird as the sounds I was
very excited every time I [__] up I
[__] up a bunch of times because every
time I [__] up I was like oh I over
watered oh I underwatered oh I gave it
too much attention you know that was
actually one of my biggest takeaways
last year was I gave my tomatoes too
much data too much science too much
attention you know I fed it too much I
gave them too much nutrients I did all
of that where they were sickly
[__] so if anything was like
trying to like you know make their life
hard they would [__] you know get [__]
you know
um but anyways on that though is is
right like even just like kind of
talking about like what we've kind of
even started talking on that dialogue
during those times when we first started
talking I grew up you know like I mean
I've showed you pictures of my parents
place and stuff you know their [__]
chewers [__] right you know
backyards you got like a pond like a
[__] com tree hanging over everything
Thomas's dog food eggs
grade A stuff dude shout out to my dad
dude
she's a guy if he was a white guy he'd
be a white supremacist like maybe for
Real uh or at least a redneck at the
very least you know
um but anyways
you know chicken eggs if you raise them
right they're not a cheap I mean maybe
nowadays but like you know like when
before the egg prices got crazy growing
your own eggs it's not it wasn't the
most um you want to do it for Budget
reasons like meaning the total cost of
getting like let's just say like your
GMO eggs or whatever of course Farmers
Market dollar each eggs even then I
don't know if you're raising that in a
way that you're buying everything the
supply of the chickens
it's gonna cost you a lot of money yeah
I mean before obviously before the
chicken eggs price away like 3.99 for a
dozen [__] nothing exactly now again
shout out to Thomas lewd you know my dad
like you know people come over and like
they look at um you know my parents
backyard like man my parents must be
hippies and you know they're all about
like nature Huntington Library yeah and
this and that right but uh dude Thomas
that [__] loves giving them dog
food because dog food his logic is this
I guess he's got a point right but long
story shortages is you know he grew up
with animals where they get whatever's
around right so [__] gets the
cheapest dog food you could buy at
Costco obviously the biggest bag and
that's their main portion of their diet
do they get some grain yes but the main
portion is gonna definitely be dog food
yeah which is it's fine chickens could
totally eat it chickens could they're
[__] walking dinosaurs they need
whatever the [__] they want really eggs
are great yeah yeah
um but that's Thomas's way but you know
our like even like my gardening Journey
though really kind of started around
that time when we first started talking
again so like that's where like you know
we're doing all those stupid Tick Tock
like uh you know eat the romaine and
then you know leave the bottom and then
like it but it never turns into a Roman
and then it's bitter as [__] and then
you're like these [__] internet
[__] so look I'm not gonna lie
in the way okay
obviously like I know when people are
bullshitting even in like gardening and
stuff to a certain degree but I got
swindled a lot the first week I was like
yeah I'm gonna regrow everything you
know which some things do you you
[__] take uh like you know those
green onions yeah no matter what you do
if you put it in the ground and keep it
like relatively moist it's gonna [__]
come up but anyways that's where my real
kind of gardening Journey grew because
again I'm tying my parents in because I
grew up with a lot of like I guess
hippie organic type culture because you
know my mom she's mad she were so you
know country like and so she's like
you know she she grew up growing her her
food you know like greens and all of
that so I grew up with all of that stuff
you know that's why I still even though
I'm a fatty and I'll eat like the most
terrible Foods I also love
Just Grains you know because I grew up
eating that type of stuff anyways
bringing that all tied together is like
my parents man like
that gardening experience of course has
helped me but like the real thing
started during pandemic and then
basically from pandemic that's when I
kind of got more and more into it right
and then you know I moved into uh I
moved into my parents
um my parents uh investment uh property
house uh and then you know like now that
I had a yard I'm like okay I'm gonna
start trying to [__] around right
and you know that whole gardening thing
too you know
people are like well why do you continue
to do it even though you messed up it's
like gardening's actually very
therapeutic for me like there's
something about I wasn't even as far as
this year I didn't buy a single tomato
plant I germinated everything [__]
thing yeah because you thought you were
gonna fail and you thought that you know
you might have less than you would you
do like you so it's like 70 plus seeds
yeah yeah and then guess what happened
yeah it did happen because once again
California weather is [__] weird yeah
it hailed it rained for three like
hurricane [__] rain [__] yeah [__]
half of them caught blight they got
[__] up and I was like good and then
the ground temperature I don't know it's
probably warmer here but you know I'm up
by the mountain oh yeah your place is a
lot colder yeah yeah and so there was
this period where it was like warm where
at night time it was like staying around
like 40-ish I'm like oh it could survive
because I wanted to harden them off and
then all of a sudden out of nowhere at
night [__] hail wreck them and I'm
like well there goes half of them
partying them off is uh you know when
you you when you get them prepped for
growing up in this ideal environment and
then you're like hey [__] why
don't you hang out not outside outside
but like in a shaded area or something
where it can kind of get used to it yeah
so if you don't harden off your tomato
plants
um what happens is it's like the leaves
are very very tender and if you felt a a
tomato plant that was actually kind of
let's say in a greenhouse outside versus
something indoors it's like literally
baby skin and then [__] ajashi
handshake skin yeah yeah yeah shout out
to all of the all of those um you know
shout out to [__] influencers who are
like useful in the sense of like that
type of stuff oh dude you know what I
mean like dudes and again you know for
sure there's obviously some frauds in
there but you know what I realized
what's so amazing about like YouTube
these days I mean obviously it's been
like this for a while but I guess it's
just putting it into words is like
even if you have a big ego
about your brand and who you are and
let's say you're a [__] douchebag
like let's say gardener the cool part is
is when you make a claim you have just
as many other hungry cats who are going
to expose you and do
science projects to debunk you yeah yeah
yeah yeah based off of human ego and
jealousy and trying to get more clicks
and more money for me as a consumer
I get a lot of good benefit because I'm
like dude these [__] because
they hate each other so much or you know
of course I'm looking at it from that
you know of course there's a lot of
reasons why people like start you know
using science to debunk each other right
you want to do that in the scientific
Community right because you want to find
the truth of something objectively
whatever with all the variables or
whatnot right so
I feel like it's interesting because
YouTube people can get really good at
the science of a lot of things because
people are gonna battle test you on a
large form right the problem with like
yeah like Labs where everything's all
um you got a budget right and with that
budget you know the r d department has a
budget and you know they're going to
reach out to I don't know you know those
like mailers where like you know you go
and you're part of a [__] experiment
or like a statistic or something right
and it happened really well with
gardening like I just remember like even
a couple of years before when I first
tried you know gardening one of the
biggest things that people said was oh
when you plant your Tomatoes throw Epsom
salt in there yeah yeah yeah yeah you
know and then people were like no that
only works yeah specific yeah yeah the
small container they're going to need it
but that took somebody to be like hey
shut the [__] up yeah yeah you're wrong
because every video prior to that was
you have to use epsom salt yeah yeah
yeah yeah and so it's like that's what
you're talking about right there where
there's like this evolution of
information it's like this isn't true
and then after they got called out now
all the videos are you don't need to
have some salt yeah and then you get the
people who just like take all of the
data and then they hash it together and
then they generically put it all
together but then they're a boring
person oh yeah yeah you know and then
you know it's like okay how many times
do I have to hear it's you know you you
get root rot because of this reason and
that and you hear the same thing over
from every single person and then at
some point like you just know that that
person never tried it themselves they
just said it because they saw that that
happens you know like they never made
the mistake themselves you know
gardening honestly reminds me of like
food like you you have to just do it to
know what the [__] is wrong you know
what I mean anything yeah like something
small that I that I thought about this
year was like you know plants are
healthy right now because I understand
watering better not from a scientific
standpoint of just doing it yeah you
know what I mean yeah yeah and if
somebody asked me now they're like well
how do I water I can give you the same
advice that I always read online stick
your finger in about an inch or two if
it's dry then you Pro it probably needs
water right but even that doesn't like
you know and then guess what you have to
make an adjustment because when the
plant grows bigger and it's more
vigorous and fruits are there that
container is going to dry up like that
yeah because the size that it is now I
have watered it fill up the oils maybe
every four or five days guess what what
that planet is [__] six feet tall
that's every day you know but there's
like things that you just know from just
starting it from seed yeah yeah for sure
because I you know I was thinking that
yeah it just speaking about tomatoes
right like I told you this I didn't want
to go through like you know again
because I got I'm juggling other things
in my life right now too where you know
I have to kind of prioritize obviously
you know my other random side projects
and other stuff but
um
germination is like its own thing to
geek about right it's like in food like
you know bread program you know like
bread you know separate that you don't
match the yeast you know what I'm saying
versus you know whatever right same
thing [__] germination like you know
which is basically you know getting the
seeds to go you know you know uh that
part I was like dude
I want to get the Tomato part down first
you know what I mean so I bought
seedling I would go buying seedlings or
I like I you know I freeload you know
cuttings from you know obviously anybody
whoever right and obviously you're
you're literally starting my my Alpha
generation of tomatoes right uh
obviously you know I'm gonna try to get
some more of the varieties and you know
we'll share our notes and stuff but you
know like uh [__] I forgot was talking
about
I relegated to cooking and food and
learning and adjusting and then
oh yeah again going back to the data and
Science and people hashing the data
together I think it's amazing like when
you get to a point where you can listen
to all of these crazy people get the
right data I start Tomatoes or any
project
trying to learn all the mistakes that
everybody's kind of hashed together yeah
so my first year I learned a lot of
things and I made a [__] ton of mistakes
you know did was I able to actually get
tomatoes and harvest and have what a
pretty good yield yeah not bad honestly
like I could I literally I could have
done it like maybe 10 times better than
I did the first year I didn't do bad but
the cool part was every time something
didn't work or didn't go as planned I
knew exactly what I did wrong you know
so that part like that's where I felt
really good after that season you felt
like you yeah did you feel like you well
the watering was issue because you had a
drip system though I did but that didn't
happen until like
probably again I don't know how long my
season lasted but let's just say let's
break it down the percentages
um or I only started to kind of figure
out watering and I don't fully have it
down yet but I got it down like maybe
three quarters into my growing season so
those first three [__] quarters
Tomatoes were like
you know what I mean like
you're going you're like oh shit's bad
then you go like this is the Tomato yeah
fall off and [__] you know so anyways
like I didn't feel that until way later
you know but
that's cool because at least now I know
and I read about you know again like
people who are over aggressive with
watering and this and that so it was
cool to know like that was something
that I can definitely fix and I got much
better by that three-quarter oh I'm
doing the oils this year dude like
um I wanted to do a drip system but my
tomatoes are scattered so far everywhere
yeah it was just too much so I was like
yeah let's just do the oil and see what
happens yeah and even oils are a little
tricky they're not as easy as people say
yes you're [__] you know you're
you're freaking you know Dave so so you
know you can get Noah for each one of
those you know for me I'm like hmm where
can I get these uh ceramic things for
five cents you know well not fifty
dollars so like uh surprisingly like
Armstrong has some cheap oils oh okay so
online they're [__] expensive as [__]
so I was going to do the thing where you
get two terracotta pots glue them
together yeah yeah yeah but then went
down that rabbit hole too exactly so the
ones at Armstrong right like an oil like
this big which online's like 7 70 bucks
Armstrong 20 bucks yeah yeah and so and
then 20 bucks oh that's great dude it's
20 [__] your best friend for not
telling me about it because you know I
got that and they're doing it yeah yeah
yeah
you know the you know I think that's the
cool thing and always being the the
material where it's it's surround or
it's the type of terracotta yeah there
it's sorry it's a [__] terracotta
[__] do this but it's like porous so
when you put water in it it leeches out
into the soil so it's like nice and
smooth and it gets there and you know
you don't have to water it all the time
you just fill that up when you're
supposed to it was like this yeah yeah
African technique where you know that's
how you save money on watering too
because the plant The Roots inherently
the tomato plants will grow towards the
Terracotta and actually grow around it
yeah yeah and it'll suck all the water
that it needs but you can't just do it
off jump you still have to water
regularly for the first two weeks in
order for the roots to grow around yeah
it's got to reach it's got to get to the
point yeah exactly so um like the first
two plants that I bagged I didn't do
that and I was like I was looking weak
as [__] and I was like oh and I did a
little research I was like oh my [__]
bad I thought the Terracotta was gonna
take care of everything yeah yeah it's
looking a little more healthier now but
I'm back on to the topic of uh like the
shrooms and what it did for you like it
was interesting because we were in the
car and you know you're talking about
you know this is obviously rapson with
the whole part of like being honest and
kind of seeing yourself in the mirror
yeah um
like what was your experience like while
doing shrooms
so
I did it
five times now it's been my fifth time
and like for me is like you know like
it's like obviously recent and also like
for me I know like you know how people
have been using it like in the
underground like in terms of like for
therapeutic use right
um to deal with trauma anxiety you know
this and that right and we talked a
little bit about it right
um
because I'm a little high right now it's
kind of hard to remember the timeline of
which exact experience was when and what
but
definitely the first time it was like a
very profound experience where
I was talking with my partner and we
basically spent the whole night talking
and it was just fascinating because that
person she was sharing
um
about like you know where she's gone in
her career and you know even just like
family and just you know things like
that right and
I could literally visually see her face
changing to the mold of like what she
was
like symbolically in a way right so like
when there's a point where like I even
like imagine like not imagine like I saw
it before my eyes her in her like Silver
Fox years and she was like in a way
speaking in front of a crowd uh her
insights about like you know the
industry that she's in you know and like
it was like I can see that visually
right
um so that experience was really
interesting because like
we basically talked the whole night and
we were able to kind of almost even
enter a different channel of our
relationship to a certain degree
um which is like fascinating because
it's like you know me and my partner
were like pretty communicative like we
talk a lot
um and
with that it's just like you kind of at
some point when you've been with
somebody for a while you
you know your channels of like
communication and like the things start
tapering off and like let's say maybe
new things you might learn about a
person and it's not like I learned
anything new but it was just fascinating
just to look at it from a different
perspective which in the end the net
positive was we became closer you know
um or maybe even more vulnerable in a
good way or we opened up to each other
more or we let even more of our guard
down and I think we have a pretty low
guard with each other
um
yeah I'd say like you know we're pretty
pretty close in terms of the the low
guard that we have with each other and
what I mean by the low guard is like
I don't know
I'm not gonna quantify that maybe it's
just like you're just you're comfortable
to be honest with each other yeah to be
like honest even like down to like every
single detail right yeah everything that
matters right
um
again you know obviously it's not like
you know we know everything about each
other and all of that stuff too you know
you're not the first couple that I heard
that did this like um my first talked
about it on their podcast but when they
had a rough patch in their marriage yeah
and
that you know one person was a little
incapable of understanding the other
person's emotion yeah albeit this
[__] on the Spectrum so yeah
get it but they did some psychedelic
[__] yeah and then this [__]
just ended up crying and like opening up
all this other [__] I told you I [__]
cried so much in the last four years two
or three years yeah like you know and it
was just all stuff that he just didn't
do was the problem or the stuff that he
was thinking about yeah yeah yeah
because he's such a binary person
everything is black and white when that
gray area where he had to think and sit
and his emotions happened it kind of
made him like oh I I can empathize now
like I get it yeah yeah you know I get
what this person is saying you know yeah
I mean that's exactly why uh what's that
dudes dude Michael Paulin like his his
book and Netflix series how to change
your mind like you know sometimes like
you know a title or something and then
you watch it and you forget that the
title is exactly well thought out for
what it is yeah
it does change your mind on a lot of
things yeah so
like another experience that I can kind
of share or kind of remember clearly was
my most recent one where
I was looking at myself in the mirror
right
um and then it was just I saw every part
of like
the ugliness of myself like
like I was seeing it right and again
just like how like you know like my
partner's face changed to that Silver
Fox that same like looking at myself I
was looking at myself but it was
there was a point where it looked like
like dude I'm like I get so scared
I get so scared like about like monster
stuff and whatever like you know like if
I woke up and there was like a little
baby saying come play with me running at
me I would just die right there right I
don't believe in any of that stuff but
it's easy for me to say that but if I
saw a little baby running towards me in
the middle and I'm like you know I would
probably just die okay anyways [__] why
did I bring that up um
silver fox
saying yourself in the mirror seeing all
the ugly stuff about you
yeah so I was looking at myself and it
was just a nasty looking site like it
was still myself but like you know I
have a [__] ton of moles but the moles
looked really [__] grimy right
I just looked in a way that I knew that
I was just this is the result of my poor
relationship with my health and my poor
relationship with food as well too
um
and then also I started thinking about
like another experience I had with a
friend in which I was so sad that this
friend couldn't kind of face uh his
reality
me myself I'm like I was sad in that
moment for that friend but I should be
sad for my [__] self right now where
like
how could I also have any like type of
insight on anyone's life
and talk about how much I love life when
I'm not even taking care of myself too
like in the sense of like like let's say
staying healthy or like you know trying
to like you know live for the longevity
by not killing myself with my poor
relationship with food you know so it
kind of all tied together in a lot of
ways I know it sounds crazy but for me
is that idea was I needed to start
focusing on like I need to change my
face so that the next time I look at
myself
I can look like somebody who's like
proud of that appearance of like what
one might look if they actually cared
about their health or you know like that
so is that is that just in relation to
and that was also when I transitioned
right because you know like I was I
think like keto way back in the days
like super early lost a [__] ton of
weight you know like I don't know
probably like not as much as like Ed but
like you know you're a big boy you
showed me yeah I used to be like 300
plus 10 pounds but like I'm saying keto
is more in the recent years right like
it was like I don't know 2000
16 or something like that yeah yeah
um so
my relationship with food [__] what was
that where was that with that um
my relationship with food
has always been so again it's just
coming full circle and just looking at
my life and like seeing like man like
I'm an ugly person how can I have an
Insight on anybody else's life when I
say ugly person ugly person in every
aspect but in this particular trip it
was like focused on like my health you
know and like
if I want to be helpful to people for a
long time
if I'm capable of helping people then I
should do it in a way that I feel okay
with being worthy of helping somebody I
don't know if that makes sense but like
uh you just feel like you're
bullshitting yeah yeah
yeah coming from a bullshitter in a way
right yeah you know so
I mean that's like
I feel like those are good experiences
that everybody should have right and
then you know for us and I've talked
about on the podcast with me and Ed you
know well I guess all three of us like
just dealing with being extremely
overweight right like I was I wasn't 300
pounds I was close to it I was like two
wait how are you six I'm six one
so I was like too close to 290 right and
you know when you kind of live in your
own [__] filth you don't know that
you're [__] dirty you know it's just
the best way to put it for sure like
your everyday is this this is your
status quo yeah right and because you
don't know any better you start to also
just rationalize a lot of shitty things
that are happening in your life be like
oh this is just me right and for me my
lie to myself
was oh I'm fat because I have to be
funny hmm right and it was a little bit
true though yeah it's like how more
people are more critical like
this is a fat guy thing man if you get a
stain on your shirt and you're fat you
know some somebody sees you as like yeah
of course that [__] fat
motherfucker's got a stain on his shirt
anyways but you know in that in that
type of sense too it's like you know you
kind of use this as a crutch right like
you have to be fat to be funny yeah it's
like no fat is not an identity you know
what I mean because if that was the case
the most famous comedians would all be
fat as [__] yeah yeah they're not yeah
why it's because they don't rely on a on
the stupid like on either like a moniker
or a prop or whatever the [__] that it
is right and having to be having to deal
with that losing weight for me was hard
because fat David was my identity that's
my identity yeah because I mean you got
to work with what you what you what you
got in a way yeah yeah obviously too
like being a big guy and starting off
younger with low self-esteem I had a
switch one day where I was like I'm
gonna make it show people like I don't
give a [__] what I am I'ma still pull
[__] I'm gonna do all this other
stuff you know what I mean
success successful know how to talk to
people get over my anxiety and I did
that all while being a [__] fat guy
yeah yeah yeah so it was almost like a
sense of Pride for me yeah for me for
sure and it's such a weird thing to
think about right now I'm sure a lot of
people don't for me this is I don't call
it like um I don't know if I'm being
like
narcissistic or something but it's
definitely a
uh what is that like what you're talking
about like
um
a lot of times
I always think I'm like the exception of
course everybody always like you know
what I mean and like but that's like
yeah then there's a fine line though too
right it's a [__] yeah yeah exactly
right like you know like I took
Taekwondo right growing up which you
know don't ever take Taekwondo if you
want to learn to fight fight
learn to fight fight and then learn some
Taekwondo for sure you know what I mean
um but anyways
you know I was fat [__] but I
can still throw a [__] beautiful like
you know like a spinning hook kick right
you know shout out to Edison Barbosa you
know being the first person in Atlanta
spin kick in the UFC
um anyways but that aspect you know I
always wanted to be the exception yeah I
want to be the fat guy who could still
get uh a pretty girl or something like
that you know for sure that was I I
totally feel you yeah and you know that
was also a point of Pride like even in
sports and even all my friends just like
dude you're [__] fast for somebody
your size it's like and I probably fed
off that type of [__] yeah yeah you know
and conversely now like now I see it in
other people and that was the place that
I used to be in yeah it's like you're
almost like scared to change
um because your identity is too hooked
to the person that you shouldn't be yeah
yeah which is very [__] weird that's
a weird Next Level [__] sabotage
and so yeah we're all [__] aliens
dude
and then when I started to lose weight
and I started to feel better not even in
the physical sense which is something
that comes along with it yeah but it's
just like like physical in terms of like
internally I felt better yeah like for
sure sleeping better yeah yeah yeah walk
a little faster yeah I don't get the
itis because of better food choices and
stuff yeah yeah I'm like damn this is a
better way to live yeah yeah and you
know there's moments too because food to
me is an addiction it's a hardcore Ass
Addiction yeah yeah like and also
emotional eater too right oh for sure
you know what I mean for sure like even
like my copy or sad happy or sad mainly
for me happiness because like I love
food so much for sure even how I connect
with my parents just through food
through my mom is food uh so every spot
every November that's what we did my
parents a simple life my mom can [__]
go down like a [__] that's why
we called her up for the kimchi you know
what I mean how do we do this my mom's a
cook person but that's you know you
gotta eat that same coop for like two
weeks yeah you know where at some point
you don't heated them you just you know
you've had every cook in every [__]
Multiverse of cooks yeah
cold temperature anyways yeah and so
like you know with that whole whole part
of like food being a part of your
identity even in your personal
relationships and even with family it
starts to affect you because now it's
like you almost can't say no to food
ever for sure I I couldn't say [__]
go to Food yeah for sure and even now I
can't but now I just portion it better
yeah yeah you pick and choose your
battles and then you pick and choose
what and who you're gonna do it with
exactly it's also like you know when
you're full you know just
stop yeah yeah yeah or just know like
okay you ate a lot of food so you have
to work this off later for me it's like
lying dude I'm telling you you know I
gotta remind myself oh
I should stop eating now yeah yeah yeah
well let them taste it whenever this guy
like he throws something at his place
and we get the crew together hey we
gonna eat it's gonna happen yeah but
it's funny right because we have like
also kind of like sometimes though
depending on which friends though some
of my friends are simple eaters right so
then it's going to be When in Rome you
know it's like about getting like you
know 40 pack of chicken nuggets from
McDonald's you know as opposed to like
you know
you know like roasted uh smoked duck
press breast shaving over Foie you know
something like that right yeah yeah
anyways um we'll do both
we're both man yeah we'll could even go
back and wrap it around like when we
were talking about food snobbering one
of the biggest comments that I used to
get you know from people who think that
they I'm not saying like I'm this person
who knows food yeah yeah but like people
who think that they know food but you
got a lot of hours
you put a lot of work exactly you know
look it's degenerate and all of that but
dude at some point yeah
I started actually getting a palette for
[__] all you can eat sushi yeah so
even to this day right what did I say
for earlier dinner Sushi yeah it was the
spot I really want to try yeah you know
it's it's still again when in Rome you
know that's what I grew up on yeah
exactly and so like when you know when
people for example
um had a conversation with our mutual
friend of ours who were you know she was
you know she knows I do food and you
know I started cooking food or whatever
yeah she saw me eat a filet-o fish and
she was like can't believe you eat that
stuff and I looked at her in disgust
yeah I was like the audacity excuse me
say what did you say yeah I was like she
was like well you like do food now like
why do you eat this stuff I was like
this is [__] delicious what is it
what are you talking about nonsense and
I also had a sausage egg muffin yeah
this is when I had to flip my [__] and
this is the most stupid thing to flip
your [__] about she does but I don't
even understand why you eat that sausage
it's not even a real egg yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah I don't need I don't need
a pre-frozen fish you know you know like
it's the freshest ever
dry age fish yeah you know you know or
when people are like you know oh
suit like you know Sashimi gray fish
like it's the freshest ever it's not
that's just they flash freeze that [__]
yeah yeah yeah for sure you know but you
know you could tell people that's all
they want but they just they just always
know better but I'm like listen
I'm not trying to yuck your yum yeah
yeah find that [__] delicious yeah it is
what it is yeah yeah when I like it I
could I could have the [__] little
thing with you know creme fraiche caviar
with this little chive okay wait
speaking of sorry sorry to interrupt but
speaking of the fish sandwiches right
McDonald's filet-o fish okay
I haven't looked am I allowed to talk
about other businesses yeah business
okay so you know like a shout out to may
you know uh May Lynn over at a you know
day Bird right neighbor Taiwanese fried
chicken sandwiches baby yeah you [__]
you know when it's on point like that
sandwich is [__] legendary right and
it's like a [__] boogie board that
comes out talk about my pockets I say
she's my favorite female chef right now
yeah but dude Mesa May shout out though
but May's got uh got that face to be
intimidated about like her default faces
like she's ready that's why her [__]
food I think she's gonna fire me and I
don't even know you know what I mean
like I'm like What's the mailing don't
fire me I actually had her food first
for the first time at Lacey oh word word
she did the private dinner thing with uh
uh Clara invited her for her birthday oh
yeah and this is before she opened up
Night song that's when I was doing keto
was it night song or her restaurant no
no it was
um
yeah so anyway shout out to me but you
know she got fried chicken sandwich but
she just recently also put out a a fried
fish sandwich right oh for reals yeah so
up until this point honestly I haven't
had it but you know I obviously know me
as a [__] killer and she can make
some good [__] food and you know like
of course like there's always gonna
potentially be consistency across the
world what I'm saying is when she makes
that [__] chicken sandwich the way
that she wants it to be made
I'm sure it's gonna taste good
um on top of that you know there's like
a caviar option that you can do right
and look
it's an 80 [__] sandwich if you put
the caviar but the sandwich itself is
whatever expensive normal sandwich that
you get nowadays anyways right so
people are gonna be real mad about an 80
sandwich which I get but at the same
time it's kind of like I don't know if I
was a baller and like I had like caviar
as part of my regular inventory and I
can afford it yeah of course I want to
eat [__] because it's gonna work you
know I want to eat [__] Fried Chicken
exactly and I want to do that with my
fried fish sandwich too if I can look
I'm on a budget these days so you know
I'm probably getting shout out to me but
I'm gonna get the regular one when I go
but outside of that before that fish
sandwich again I'm already claiming that
it's good even when I haven't even tried
it which is like obviously like but
again you know you just know it's like
[__] Kirkland it's gonna be on point
you know
um I'll tell you this man and
yeah a lot of people
this is like the other thing I don't
like about food sometimes yes like I
like caviar right yeah but when I see
people eat caviar and they're rolling
their eyes to the back of their head I'm
like that's [__] fish eggs bro
there's a lot of other things in this
world that'll make you do that I don't
think it's caviar and I love caviar
right I like fish row I've had it my
whole life called out right now hey let
me tell you something you son of a [__]
I did this in Japan when I had you know
like again Japan doesn't have everything
that's the best but the things that
they're good at I did do I look dude for
real real talk my eyes did real back
okay let me tell you something like I
enjoy it a lot right but when people I'm
specifically talking about sturgeon
caviar got it yeah yeah of course and I
see like Gordon Ramsay well that's not
sorry they're interrupt one more time
you know LA River like 40 years ago or
something like that and again I'm gonna
probably have to fact check myself on
this but the LA River had [__]
sturgeon in it oh 100 the American river
in Sacramento I grew up people people
fish for sturgeon they have it so can
you imagine dude being [__] like you
know down like uh the bike path in
Frogtown and then like you see
prehistoric animals the fool with a 40
and then like you know on his like Low
Rider bike and then you look down and
then there's a [__]
the American River uh people fish for
that for my group in Sacramento so we
saw that [__] but I see Gordon Ramsay
and he takes this yeah yeah and he eats
like it's the most amazing thing he's
ever had in his life I'm like okay
listen here you [__] yeah
it's yeah it's delicious right it's even
the same concept when I see people eat
uh truffle right yeah yeah like and they
just oh truffles is the best yeah yeah
yeah it is not the best it is it is
something that's good with something
else yeah and it's a part of a luxury as
well too like there there's you're a lot
you're a [__] liar to say that
truffle is as good as it just it's I'm
saying is there's just as much of
the exclusivity of a black truffle again
black truffle is amazing yeah it's
delicious yeah for sure get it but
there's also definitely an aspect of
that you know luxury and separation you
know like you know bling it out or I
don't know what a young people call yeah
because you know
having a conversation with friends about
the tour of Foodies and they're like oh
you're [__] crazy I was like cool let
me put it to you like this yeah yeah I
have a [__] gun to your [__] face
yeah yeah right yeah I have I was like
what's your favorite Cuisine they go
Vietnamese food what's your favorite
Vietnamese dish they're like um it's
bunrio I'm like cool I have a bowl of
Boone real and you're about to [__]
die I'm gonna blow your [__] head off
and I have a white truffle nugget what
are you eating yeah yeah yeah you're
eating the [__] what they're like
obviously that why because it's a more
complete dish for sure and it's
infinitely more delicious Than This One
Piece yeah yeah yeah I told you right
now we're not talking about price we're
talking about what you want to eat yeah
yeah yeah that for sure I was like
that's why I think you're full of [__]
yeah so yeah I'm not saying that truffle
is disgusting I love truffle like you
have shave truffle on just like some
buttered potatoes yeah God damn
Delicious yeah yeah yeah I mean but that
little thing right there when I see
people just talk about it because of the
luxury aspect of it yeah yeah it's like
come on let's be real here man I'm I'm
taking if somebody offered me like two
slice of just white truffle right some
of the most highest quality [__] that
shit's like 60 bucks for like whatever
announce of it or whatever yeah yeah
yeah you put a flail fish next to me
yeah yeah yeah I'm hungry
man
[Music]
was when her restaurant closed I was
[__] sad like it was my top probably
like five restaurants in La at the time
got it um she was so she's very creative
and her photo was always fun and it
executed really well
um this is what I think though that's
also a lot of fun about like kind of I
don't know how to say like the modern
movement but like the one like the chefs
who
were trained let's say classically and
then also like trial by fire where they
work the line in these like high
pressure environment you know
um Farm to Table you know like that type
of you know
industry right the real toxic one at
times right
I mean I guess the movie Chef is like
this too right is you know with Roy
Choice shout out to really Choi but like
you know like is
this also philosophy of like just taking
something that's not fancy but just
doing it with proper technique care AKA
giving a [__] yeah you know like
I don't know what's more attractive to
any type of human being is to me is a
lot of times when they're giving a [__]
about anything yeah yeah you know what I
mean of course you can give a [__] about
things that are like not like you know
you shouldn't be giving a [__] about but
I mean like the things that you know
create value to let's say another person
that they want to consume or something
you know
yeah I mean yeah I mean like like food
has become
you know I feel like in like the like
the 80s right yeah yeah when somebody
opened up a restaurant and we're
obviously not talking about highfaloon
restaurants you're not talking about the
place you saw in Time Magazine yeah but
a lot of these mom and pop stores or
even some of these independent
businesses when they were opening up
restaurants it was done at a necessity
yeah yeah yeah right and now it's done
at a passion worse right yeah you're
getting to see people really just step
up their game in terms of what they do
in other places not so much yeah but I'm
really enjoying this movement of
watching these high fancy chefs being
like [__] this I just want to make what
I want to make yeah this is where it
gets real complex too right is because
like for example right I'm a la native
right I was born and raised in Southern
California
imagine you're
you know like growing up never went to
Mexico okay but I would eat La street
tacos a lot and also like the
establishments right
um I grew up with that but you know like
I'm in my 40s now right
so I spent pretty much a big portion of
my life eating La street tacos right and
I don't know what tacos might have
tasted like again obviously I've gone
since but like when I was younger up
until a certain point of my age like
I did grow up with a full childhood or
almost a whole generation eating
something that's not like part of my
ancestry but is also something that that
that's not specific to like it's not
like I was eating tacos in Mexico yeah
yeah yeah you know what I'm saying yeah
and then mix that with like you know
obviously everybody uh every Korean
[__] has like you know uh uh meat
lying around in their house in the sense
of like when times are good right you
got your bugi you got your Kirby you got
whatever right and whatever Korean
barbecue staple meats that you might
have that you eat right you're gonna
have leftovers at times right and those
leftovers you're gonna combine that with
the tortilla that you're gonna get and
again it might start out with the
[__] Mission tortilla and then it
might end up at some point you know
turning into a [__] Masa from [__]
the original guisados and Boyle Heights
like the [__] Tortilla Factory where
they make the Masa and you pick it up
and that's what grisados uses I don't
know if they still use it to this day
right but you know whatever extremity is
is I still grew up and I can see like
where Roy choice you know again it's
it's a dated concept right but you know
mixing an obvious leftover a necessity
of Korean barbecue let's say and then
you have tortillas lying around then
it's like a immediate marriage right
yeah um anyway so I think it's
fascinating that in this modern culinary
world with a lot of the restaurants or
things that you see
a lot of it's like comfort and junk food
or things that people grew up eating and
going and accessing that's not
pretentious but just kind of adding more
like giving a [__] using like you know
the technical techniques that you learn
right
um from trial by fire in those kitchens
you know 100 like there's this
restaurant I tried it's called Uh Mr T
out in Los Angeles and the I believe the
head chef is Thai is a female Thai Chef
but she's taking like aspects of stuff
that she grew up eating from her mom and
then repackaging and repurposing it and
just executing it yeah differently right
yeah yeah and it's like whoa this tastes
like this but it's different enough
where it's elevated here and elevated
doesn't necessarily mean better than
that dish yeah it's just tightened up a
little bit yeah you know what I mean
yeah yeah yeah that's where that fun
comes in it's like whoa this is really
[__] delicious and it's a little more
precise and you know part of the the the
the enjoyable part about Mom and Pop's
place is that it's in the chaos like
it's not precise you know what I mean
some days it's going to taste like this
some days it's gonna be a little
different maybe a little spicy yeah a
little extra sweet sometimes sure for
sure and that's kind of like that home
feel that I really enjoy sometimes but
when you go into this restaurant area
they start to become meticulous about it
x amount of tablespoons here the
millimeter width of this vegetables it's
like here yeah yeah yeah so every time
you eat it's the same enjoyable
experience dude you know where I get
anxiety though when it comes to food and
like because I'm a ratio guy
so like you know like a ratio guy ratio
Foods Korean people are ratio people to
the max but then at the same time though
you know what gives me [__] [__] ton
of anxiety
like when you're going eating out and
eating panchan uh and you know like the
loose punch ends the one where it's like
you know Choose Your Own Adventure like
you can or you like there's no you can't
like there's some manchans where you can
pretty much eat with everything right
for me it's just like let's say I'm
eating like Korean barbecue and there's
a [__] ton of panchan I get like anxiety
because I'm trying to keep and maintain
my ratio where because I'm doing a
constant ratio battle I'm never stopping
so like there's no rest because I'm like
oh you grab the bottom meat oh I need a
little bit of duck I need a little bit
of this and then it just keeps going in
this endless loop until there's
obviously no more food you know who's a
ratio guy [__] uh Ed oh yeah Ed I
heard this about Ed yeah for sure like
I've never noticed until I saw it yeah
yeah and it was everywhere that we went
right yeah yeah yeah whenever you see Ed
just notice like on his last bite I do
the exact same thing like everything's
down to racial the last fight has to
have every component from which you
started I see I'm not like that yeah I
get you I'm yeah people are normal
that's crazy I get it I'm gonna I'm
gonna add on that too you know [__]
santuka Ramen yeah you know the little
Plum yeah
don't tell me you [__] Robin that's
[__] ridiculous I have multiple
people in my life that can fact check me
on this can I tell you guys something
that Plum is the size of my pinkiness
already taking one bite out of it
you know you got to use your Precision
Thumpers absolutely [__] nonsense
because it's all seed and then there's I
need you to not do that anymore yeah
there's like a milk there's a millimeter
of meat right like between the seed and
the meat so the last bite of [__]
salt santuka Ramen the size of this
power button not this remote yeah that's
how small it is so the bowl is this big
So when you say Edge one of those guys
I'm one of those guys too
that's okay I understand yeah that's
ridiculous it's an example it's the
first thing I can think of that is crazy
but again this is also why with Korea
barbecue maybe because a big I mean of
course I'm a fat ass but like I mean you
know like in here I'm a fat ass like I
can I get that like so you know it's
like I don't know what's that one in
place like you know I'll go for free but
I'll never go to pay for it quinoa right
I think I like panchans Galore right
dude I'm just like because it's like
anxiety because I'm like I need to try
to get every little bite and then it
just endless loop of it you know yeah
it's interesting when I see uh ratios
like you know what I really [__] with
like Asian food I feel like Asian food
really understood the idea of acid and
dishes that yeah you know growing up
when I had when I would always eat like
American food yeah it was just always so
[__] heavy of course Korean people
would always ask where's the kimchi yeah
yeah Kraft mac and cheese yeah which by
the way [__] delicious still one of
my favorite Mac and cheeses of all time
Nostalgia baby
like you know they would have that and
then every time I never understood why
my mom was like I need kimchi I need
kimchi and it's just she needed
something fermented she needed something
you know a little [__] said you know
Korean Supreme
every time like even I remember I made
Thanksgiving food right yeah yeah she's
like I need some kimchi though and I
would always tell like you're ruining
the food I was like actually she's not
because it's so heavy I mean turkey
stuffing mashed potatoes gravy uh
macaroni and cheese and then there'll be
like some type of roasted vegetable yeah
and there was no acid anywhere there was
no pop of anything and I'm like now I
get this like this makes the best you
get is cranberry sauce exactly the best
you guess it's dessert to me yeah yeah
you know so like you know when I first
had Thai food right yeah I remember that
[__] it felt like an explosion of flavor
in my [__] face yeah yeah for sure
and I was like what definitely party in
your mouth yeah and you know very
different from Vietnamese Chinese Korean
and Japanese which was like my main
Staples and I remember I had
um Tom Yum sure ate that [__] and I was
like this is I don't know what the [__]
this is delicious but when you smell it
it smells a little bit like [__] on
fingers no no fish sauce fish sauce fish
sauce fish sauce specifically yeah
yeah but
when you smell it you know it's like
look I'm [__] dirty [__] but
you know like when you still got a
little bit of juices on your butthole
you know
you know you you know when you're
younger you go and you you're like oh
shoot and then you know
not just poo in the wild or not poo
right out of the butthole but once the
something the oil is in your finger
creates something that should be titled
[__] on fingers as a separate
classification of a Genus okay so shut
up fingers that [__]
fish sauce Vibes now I want you to make
a commercial for fish sauce
I want you to sell this to white people
say listen yeah no yeah yeah like you
are trying to get to know more about
Asian culture yeah I need you to stick
your finger in your [__] ass yeah
would you smell it and go lunch yeah
yeah yeah and then like you know you
come up with like some hip like name
like sof like [__] on you know like but
you never explain what it is you know
SOS uh L.A is very interesting like the
LA Food scene
um and you know this is like in
comparison to from what I've seen from
like
um New York right which is you know
there's a few places they consider
meccas right in the United States LA and
New York happened to be one of them San
Francisco coming in on a hard second
Chicago too Chicago as well I've never
been right
um
Ellie's very interesting in which what I
like about La is that La has a lot of
eateries and this is just my opinion
people can agree or disagree
um there's so many institutions here
that could give a [__] less about your
seasonal dish you know what I mean
you're around we serve the same [__] you
know and then with New York I feel like
they're trying so hard to compete in a
small space that they always have to do
the next best thing so it'll be like oh
seasonal ramps are here so we're gonna
use ramp in our dishes LA's kind of like
I'll give a [__] like this is this is
how we've had it yeah this is what we're
[__] shout out to Korean Supremacy
though you know in Korea ramps
I think there are ramps in Korea oh
really yeah I don't know what if it's
the same season it's like it would be if
it could be pickled it's in the Korean
dish exactly and you see like American
adaptations of our own side dishes that
they don't have in Korea yeah you know
what I mean yeah I mean shout out to
okay like Roy Korean Taco right but back
up more right La transplants three bone
car B right versus like the L.A Kirby
right they would call it yeah yeah yeah
for sure there's always like these weird
adaptations with like food that
um a lot of people don't understand
where it came from you know Pueblo
Mexico start interrupt the thrombo
Lebanese immigrants right they moved uh
there and then I always like again my La
part of me was like oh yeah yeah you
know I don't know any of the history or
roots of like al pastor you know like
the meat on this pit like Shawarma yeah
like literally it was [__] Lebanese
going to Pueblo Mexico and then they
[__]
adapted it in that way you know and it's
[__] delicious yeah dude it's it's
weird when I travel to other states it
does make you wonder though on the bus
store or you're like huh
in Mexican ancestors always use Tampico
in the pastor marinade like maybe
Tampico existed in Millennials okay I
would find this out from like small
things right so I have like a shrimp
cocktail recipe that I make right it's
obviously adjusted to my taste in that
life yeah yeah but then I you know
there'd be some of these videos there's
like they'll do a shrimp cocktail recipe
and I would make it I'm like this just
sucks does it taste good yeah like what
the [__] is the difference yeah and then
I'll watch this grainy ass video in 240p
yeah right with this lady
yeah
okay and it's this lady is speaking in
Spanish and then so somebody from God's
grace they translated her recipe to show
us what she's talking about yeah yeah
yeah and it's just some of the jankiest
[__] ever and I'm like that's why it
tastes good yeah it's because of that
janky ass [__] condiment right there
yeah yeah that all these other fancy
ones don't add yeah because they're
trying to make it either like fresher or
whatever I'm like [__] that yeah it
doesn't translate sometimes yeah it
doesn't translate I'm sorry like one of
the biggest things that I found out yeah
yeah for sure specifically what I went
to Mexico was a lot of people when they
were making their uh their cocktail
their Seafood cocktail they would add
[__] you know what it is baggy soy
sauce oh yeah yeah yeah yeah and that's
like in everything that they would put
in wait Maggie soy sauce or Maggie
Seasons
seasoning and that was like the
Worchester liquid
um and I was like yeah yeah ain't nobody
said [__] about this and I was like
that's why when I had it in Mexico it
was so [__] good and I just saw that
bottle I was like it was everywhere I'm
like what is that for well you know tour
guy said they're like oh we put it in
the like the campichana and the freak I
was like what the [__] after that saw
those videos I was like oh it's true
they had that [__] ton of ketchup and
that's like the main flavor base yeah
and it's [__] delicious weird yeah I
mean if it ain't bad don't fix it yeah
for sure it's so crazy right even like
Filipino ketchup like banana ketchup
yeah I always thought that like you know
like my homies who like had it their
homes
I always thought that that was just the
brand banana ketchup but it was still
Shirley tomato
so I didn't know that it was actually
banana ketchup you know because it looks
like tomato ketchup you know it's red
you know anyways like I literally
actually just learned that like a couple
years ago you know Filipino spaghetti
that's all ketchup baby yeah for sure
and a [__] ton of sugar that's [__]
addictive as hell yeah yeah for sure I I
I remember just going to like my
friend's family parties yeah but it's
still [__] better than shout out to
Thomas because he still can eat like
ravioli out of the Chef Boyardee can
cold you know when you cut into it and
it's just a Chile
I said you laid to describe [__]
tonight we have um
anyways well again it's still going to
be better than that in the sense of like
just saying like you know like it's like
people love Chef Boyardee the same
reason why people love things where at
least those things that are like you
know once you know the ingredients at
least it's still good you know what I
mean I ain't gonna lie man yeah I love
Chef Boyardee [__] Ravi Canon or
rabbit because I think you and Thomas
will be homies hey I'll tell you this
that's just dog food but I'll eat it
I'll eat it I'll eat that [__] all day
yeah yeah you know like Last of Us
Styles you know like you you know can
you imagine like if you were doing like
Last of Us Styles and all of a sudden
like you came across a Chef Boyardee
yeah I I like that [__] because it was
like very American it was food that I
didn't have in my house but some of my
other Korean friends who were more
korean-american than I was yeah yeah
they had microwave dinners they had Chef
Boyardee that was like that was like me
oh see right there and so
you know it was Price Club in the I
don't know early 90s late I can't
remember whatever right but uh I grew up
on
Kirkland like at least like my junior
high high school years you know like I
ate so many chicken fried chicken patty
sandwiches from oh my god dog you just
[__] traumatized me right Posada
burritos I don't know did they still
come Posada burritos right then they
came out with the chicken chimichangas
and those were fire but then you could
you had to stop eating them because
they're just like too much you know the
fried chicken patties my mom would buy
that every [__] time yeah yeah and
then she would just throw it I would I
couldn't even use an oven at the time so
I just microwave that [__] yeah yeah
and I would just eat that with whatever
I could I [__] forgot about that [__]
dude the fried chicken patties and there
was on top of that New England clam
chowder from [__] not Campbell's but
a Progresso yeah yeah before Kirkland
had a bunch of Kirkland branded stuff
right yeah they still had and they still
do have like Partnerships with certain
things and those are always going to be
Staples that at Kirk dude Kirkland it's
funny right because like let's say you
know they always make the joke like
Target it's like perfect for girls you
know like I don't know some transplant
from Arizona like some white blonde girl
right yeah uh Kirkland
it's also a curated brand right like
Target is curated right Kirkland is a
curated brand too right like let's Okay
so the other day like I I went to go buy
a bunch of [__] ton of shelves because
I'm trying to get my garage sorted right
I know that the base model
of the shelves
are gonna be of a certain quality
because Costco carries it because yeah
you know what I'm saying at that price
point for the quality there's always
going to be that Kirkland like a little
bit better than everything else around
that same costume it's gonna be good
yeah exactly right
um
those shelves like I had one from the
old like days of you know like uh
I don't know like little meets days I
think that like I bought a one-off and I
regret it it was like one of those
Amazon ones at around the same price the
thing is like so dinky while the Costco
shelf is like you know what I mean some
real [__] yeah so anyways just going on
that Costco life it's committed to the
brands dude and the [__] weird like
cities apart Korean people still bought
the same [__] yeah yeah what the [__] is
that about yeah for sure like when I
when I would talk to Ed about stuff
because he grew up in Seattle and his
parents are buying litter the same [__]
my parents are buying yeah and it's very
particular to Korean people yeah like
something something about that [__]
Korean war that [__] everybody up yeah
you know Thomas my dad so every time I
say Thomas I'm talking about my dad you
haven't met at me yet but he's character
dude
so
this guy
is a master saver and he
there's never not spam
soda
instant Ramen and Vienna sausage in an
unlimited Supply when I say unlimited of
course everything's finite like a
ridiculous but yeah we're talking like
like it could be a whole cupboard like a
like a cupboard when I say like from you
know ground to to ceiling of one of
those things right so instant Ramen
spam he's got a legit collection of
those things and you know those are also
things that if and when they expire
again just like The Last of Us Thomas
doesn't get he's not gonna get sick
because that spam is good for a long
[__] time even though it's past
expiration date you know that spam is
like do that folks if you you know if
something you get you know but Thomas he
comes from that era is that
quintessential like thing that every
Korean household has to have spam
because you just fry that [__] up eat it
with rice eggs and kimchi and you're
pretty much Hawaiian food it's [__]
delicious well guys but that's a
two-hour podcast baby you guys haven't
had we've done for two hours you guys
haven't had a two-hour podcast in quite
a while but uh I'm gonna title this one
um ADHD and two Koreans Yeah well yeah
and then also the [__] first 40
minutes of Robin [__] talking stupid
High dude that's way too high the one
high Korean one drunk Korean I gotta
redeem myself for that first 40 minutes
no people love [__] Randomness that's
what this podcast about the last podcast
I rambled on for about tomatoes for 20
minutes and that was the most enjoyable
part for them and I had to get it out
because I wanted to tell people about
tomatoes but uh you guys could catch
this podcast every Sundays at 12 p.m uh
genius brain uh we have a lot to talk
about oh I mean we get tough for hours
secret society is launching of course
Spring we have a secret society Jesus
brain collab coming out it has
everything to do with my love for anime
and growing up it is if you guys know
there's always a backstory to every
collab piece that I create and it's
going to be based off one of my favorite
animes of all time you're gonna [__]
love it uh once again every Sunday at 12
p.m we'll see y'all next time peace
thank you